talking about past and future and
excessive emphasis on past and future in
your life if there's nothing wrong with
having a certain intention of what you
want to achieve take steps towards it
it's part of living here in this
Dimension you can't just say I'm never
going to plan anything anymore just take
life as it comes well some people try to
do that but they're not that happy
either after a while then your life will
get very diffused to have an intention
to have to make a plan perfectly fine
either short-term plan like I'm going to
meet you tomorrow at four o'clock how
would you ever meet anybody if we didn't
have time and future in a practical
level of course it's needed the question
is whether future takes over your mind
being able to use it for practical
purposes is of course great but I call
that clock time is fine but
psychological time is When Future takes
over your mind and your entire soul
patterns are geared only towards future
and you treat the present moment as
either just a means to end because it
enables you to get to the next one
you're always reaching out so to speak
internally to the next yet never quite
here always looking for some fulfillment
there but you can never embrace the
fullness of now or you make them now
into even an enemy hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Eckhart
Tolle enjoy
some people are always unhappy you
perhaps we all know some one or two
people like that three
who are wherever they are they are
they're complaining it's never quite
right wherever they are or whoever they
are with after a little while they're
very uncomfortable again and it should
be somewhere else you know the bumper
sticker that you see in some cars in the
various versions of it says I'd rather
be golfing and then another one says I'd
rather be fishing I'd rather be this I'd
rather be there when I visited the the
spiritual teacher ramdas who lives in
Hawaii he has a bumper sticker on ramdas
was the person who in the 70s wrote the
book be here now that and anyway he has
a bumper stick on his car that says I'd
rather be here now so
and and then you realize you can
actually you can still pursue
whatever an intention where you want to
get to a plan I call it it's a bit like
a journey your life is it is a journey
you're going you know you want to go
from here to there whether you're going
to get there we don't know maybe on the
way you'll Branch out to somewhere else
but at least you have a certain
direction it's good to have some
direction in your life
but while you are traveling
if the the your destination takes up
most of your attention and you're
continuously focusing on there you miss
all the journey really you can't enjoy
the journey anymore and most of your
life is the journey the arriving is
relatively rare the wedding
and a few more graduation
but so so those moments are not the fine
view between so the rest is the journey
and if you can't enjoy the journey which
means the step you're taking at this
moment
is really the most important thing yes
of course you know you're going that way
but this step is still to be enjoyed
because that's ultimately your whole
life consists of the step you're taking
at this moment there is never anything
else for many years before I wrote The
Power of Now and it became successful I
was basically a failure in the eyes of
the world so he's already almost 50. and
what has he achieved my mom said you
have thrown away your life you had so
many possibilities in your life you
walked out of graduate school in
Cambridge why did you walk out of there
you
uh my mom said when many other people
said this person has failed in life he
has no job he has no
insurance policies nothing no pension
plan just almost nothing in the bank
failure and then a few years later
people bought the path now and became a
bestseller oh a big success okay if I
had derived my identity at that time
from what the world was telling me or my
mind would have told me if I've been
listening to my mind I would have been
very unhappy
and I didn't so I was fine
because my identity wasn't derived from
that anymore and fortunately even when
in the eyes of the world I suddenly
became a success
I don't want to derive my identity from
that it's it's a cheap substitute for
who I really am
so I'm not I don't see I don't derive
but the satisfaction it comes is the
satisfaction that
the work that's happening the teaching
that's happening is transforming
people's lives that's very satisfying
but I don't get any personal
satisfaction though because it's not I
don't feel it as this separate me
produced it it's not that difficult
really to step out of the stream of
thinking to
um one way of course is meditation it's
the traditional approach is you have
certain periods of time once or twice a
day when you sit down close your eyes
and instead of involuntarily being drawn
into the continuous stream of thinking
you usually in with meditation you have
a technique or method you focus your
attention on one thing which could be a
mantra that you preach it could be your
breathing
it's a very ancient meditation it could
be the inner feeling in your body the
sense of aliveness that pervades
pervades your body in other words you
take attention away from thinking and
that's already a great realization that
you are able you ever actually have a
choice of directing attention you don't
have to go to you don't have to go with
your attention all the time where the
habitual thought patterns want you to go
the habitual thought it runs want your
attention every time every thought says
I met like give me your attention follow
me they go this way and another negative
thought and another one and another one
compassion for yourself of course is as
important as compassion for others when
you uh often I get asked questions like
people who did something that they now
realize realize was deeply wrong in the
past sometimes people ask questions
about they brought up their children in
a way that they now realize was not very
conscious and so that they may have
caused suffering to their children or
other people find they have caused
suffering to loved ones and they now
realize that what they did was wrong and
again I say this is an example where you
need to be compassionate with yourself
because no human being can act beyond
their level of Consciousness so that was
your level of conscience at the time and
you could not go beyond that and again
here to make demands upon yourself
up to a point it might be a good thing
to to if you as long as you enjoy it
it's a wonderful thing when the
enjoyment of what you're doing is lost
then you have to be careful because
there you have to come to a stop and say
okay there's there's something here
that's not right because I'm no longer
enjoying what I'm doing also to make
sure you're at
your action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there a lot of so-called unhappiness
is also a childish way of trying to
change things
by being as unhappy as you can about
them
and the underlying unconscious or
semi-conscious assumption
is if I'm really unhappy somebody
perhaps God
is going to do something about it or I'm
going to prove him wrong
I'm going to show him how Dreadful it is
and then finally this is an unconscious
assumption behind the unhappiness
because you believe if you're habitually
and frequently unhappy you believe that
it has a purpose
it's an underlying assumption perhaps
you wouldn't verbalize it in that way
but you believe that it it's it works
for you because it doesn't but things
are going to change but just need to be
really unhappy so that God finally even
if you don't believe in God's this can
still be the mechanism the underlying
unconscious assumption behind it it's
something is going to happen
and of course the opposite is true
because the more unhappy are with
something the more you are stuck
in the situation how you do what you do
is more important than what you do you
could have a you could have a stores
serving customers with this or that
which perhaps would not be regarded as a
very uh important job and yet if that is
done with a quality of presence where
every customer comes into your store you
give this person you just an example
your fullest attention you appreciate
him or her as a human being you see how
you can best serve him or her in the
present moment that is quality and then
you would be improving everybody who
comes into contact with you would
somehow experience a small lifting in in
their being in Consciousness and so that
you could create a even a person with a
relatively in relatively simple job
could contribute in that way to creating
a better world I need my story
all the things that my I've been telling
myself in my mind about myself and other
people and my parents
and my relatives and my co-workers and
my ex-wife and my ex-husband
and what people did to me and on what or
what I did and shouldn't have done
failed to do
who am I without that I can't let go of
that I need to think about this more
so it becomes a habitual place the
habitual place of the of the mental
noise where you feel that's me
and so if every therapist knows
that you always reach a point where they
are
clients patients whatever depending on
the school of therapy depends whatever
you call the your clients your patients
whatever
there comes a point when you hit that
resistance
They Don't Want to Be Free of their
problems
and that the big challenge is there
is this person going to overcome that
barrier because that barrier is not just
becoming free of my problems
but also becoming free of a very limited
and ultimately fictitious sense of
identity
the me
so that is what I've described is the
next
step one could say in the evolution of
human consciousness
is
stepping out of
self-talk which is
the conditioned mind
and realizing there is much more to who
I am
than this conditioned content of my mind
and that
is the beginning of Awakening it's not
it's not those words not not that you
need to believe that there is much more
to who I am than the self-talk in my
head because that is still self-talk in
the head
I believe there's more to who I am
and you better believe it too analytical
thinking itself or processing
information is not creative
so to to even to find a creative a new
solution to a problem in your life
requires some creative Insight so
whether it's a problem in your work
situation or your personal life or
something that you need to build or do
and you have come to a dead end
or you want to create something whatever
it is a work of art or a new system for
the computer I don't know the
expressions for that you need to go to
the place where creativity arises and
every human
who brings who is creative has some
access to that even if they don't know
it it seems to be as a general pattern
at work
that
it is inherent in the nature of
physical existence of life forms that
challenges
unessential ingredient of
their lives and here and part of the way
through which they evolve and when they
say they Evolve Real means is the one
Consciousness evolves awakens into this
dimension
through
the different life forms in different
ways
and it awakens only because we are being
challenged
and that's already that is a
quite a relief to realize
to be Charles doesn't mean there's
something wrong
[Laughter]
there's something wrong with my knife
that shouldn't be if you believe or act
every as if this shouldn't be happening
then you get really unhappy
then the challenges become transformed
into unhappiness inside you
know if it's not unhappiness it's
resentment if it's not resentment it's
it's anger it's self-pity it's
complaining it's despondency
instead of several the simple reason
that you are misunderstanding
the very purpose of life
and expecting something that your mind
has come up with it should be different
some people are afraid of
not succeeding in whatever they do
because they have a self they they their
self-image which is derived from
thinking
uh would suffer if I fail at something
then I will myself image will be injured
and therefore I'm not even going to try
and again that's to do with deriving
your identity from thinking
and even the thought I have failed is a
lie
I am a failure is an even greater lie
you have not failed you can simply
reinterpret those I've learned something
here this is not from me for example
so but why believe the lies that your
mind produces
so
as you know people many people live with
a
very hostile mind
that's
but those people are the motivation
their motivation will probably be very
great I would hope to get out of their
minds
but first I need to realize that their
problems are self-generated mind
generated we may be surprised to know
that there are millions billions of
people on the planet who have that same
thought pattern there's something wrong
with me
it's part of the human ego but so you
bring in the awareness
and that will change
everything
that's the only true key
if you fail next time you're the anger
arises
what happens you will become aware
immediately after the anger has subsided
and then oh there it was and I wasn't
present
and then the that the moment will come
when you are there in the first if you
can catch the anger the first moment it
comes
or if you might even see that it could
be the result of a thought
that creates the anger and if you can be
there in the first moment because before
it becomes the fully blown
anger then you can stay there and it
might not even become fully blown anger
if you catch it the first moment you can
feel the first stirrings of anger you
may only have three seconds
it may come very quickly and goes like
an explosive energy
you may only have two three four five
seconds
just to to bring the stay there with
your awareness and feel it oh that it's
coming there it is that's the pain body
the angry pain body coming and if you
catch it in the early stage don't
suppress it by catch it I mean
feel it be there as the witness then
you can stay even as it grows the
witness grows with it it may not even
grow we'll have to see whether it still
grows into full-blown anger or not that
doesn't matter
and so you be thankful for your anger
because the anger can become a very
important spiritual practice for you
because through it awareness can grow
so it's it's a sometimes strange for
people to see you can be thankful for
things that you think are
the most difficult obstacles in your
life
but they become
they can become their greatest
opportunity for for Spiritual Awakening
use it
as part of your practice you can there
is a source of power in you that
transcends the person and it's not egoic
power over somebody
and it's one with the power that is the
power of life in the universe
where all life arises
and
people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence
[Music]
or
valuing yourself
and
sometimes
you try to convince yourself by changing
your thinking that
you are actually good enough
that you should be self-confident but
there is a better way
to to find
the source of self-confidence
on the egoic level self-confidence is
there because you see you can tell
yourself
I'm actually more intelligent in most of
these people
or I'm better looking than most I have
to remind myself that I'm better looking
than most and then you okay yeah I feel
a bit more confident now
or you say I actually have more money
than these people so I should I have
more self-confidence
whatever it is some way of convincing
yourself and then you compare yourself
with others and then you focus in on
those areas where you feel Superior to
others and try not to think about other
areas where inevitably you are inferior
to others because you cannot be superior
in all areas it's a complicated game
when you start start comparing yourself
to other people
and if you want to bolster yourself
confidence and you only have to focus on
where you feel I'm actually better than
most but that doesn't really work that
well
um
so there is a better way of
self-confidence that has nothing to do
with comparing yourself with others
or with feeling you are better than or
not as good as
and that is direct access
to Inner power
you don't need any comparison
you can have it right now at this very
moment
if you're not stuck in your thinking
mind
but take your attention a little bit
beyond the thinking mind
and then realize that you are
the presence behind the thinking mind
without which there could be no thinking
you're the aware presence behind it all
that that is deeper you've gone deeper
than the thinking mind
and that aware presence
is
where power resides
and it's not yours
because it connects you with universal
power
therefore you don't need to compare
yourself to anybody anymore
or feel as the ego always does
that you are either Superior or inferior
to somebody else
that's a not a comfortable way to live
where you have to classify yourself when
you meet people
and so if the fears always I might be
inferior
or behind that fear is a desire to be
superior
what happens when you pay attention to
the way in which you interact with
objects
and what is okay it's used
every minute of the day this you pick
something up you put something down you
unbutton your search you you take off
your shoes you lift this put this there
open your back zipper back
[Music]
you look inside
take something out can you feel it as
you take it out can you feel the text of
that and then you put it on the table it
makes a sound as you put it on the table
and then you have a glass of water and
the light is reflected in it
and it moves
perhaps you drink and it tastes and you
put it down again
and then you look at a familiar object
and instead of using it
always as a means to an end here you
have the luxury of occasionally
just taking an ordinary object that you
handle every day and just for a few
seconds give it give it attention and
acknowledge its being just as that as
that object just feel it see it
makes it as it makes a noise as you put
it down
and again you bring incense perceptions
getting dressed in the morning
putting his pants on they make a noise
as you put them on a little bit listen
do things
you pick up the toothpaste
you hold it for a moment
put the cap on the sink click
and then turn on the tabs
and then while you brush your teeth you
turn off the tap
because you don't want to waste water
but but that's not part of the exercise
and it's you can actually begin to like
and to enjoy the tiniest
things around you that would normally be
completely overlooked
the essence of the way in which you
interact
with a world of objects
and that brings a richness into your
life that doesn't depend on how many
objects you own you don't need to own
them to interact with them and so here
to acknowledge
their beingness and you sometimes you
might just put your hand as I'm doing
now here's a table it's wood
and I'm putting my hand on it and for a
moment I feel the smooth texture surface
of this table and it it feels very
pleasant
and I don't but I don't need the mind to
tell me that I can I can sense that
and the strange thing is
even so-called
inanimate objects
in a strange way have a life
of their own the true self-esteem comes
from not identifying with form now
whether we even want to call it
self-esteem I don't know
the true
sense of worthiness
and of power true power
comes when you realize the formless in
yourself that dimension
and that all power comes from that
but it's not it goes far beyond the
person that you are
and then you are rooted in the formless
so to speak or
you are it
and
that there's enormous
sense of worthiness in there but it's
not comparative
it's not more than
you see the same worthiness in everyone
even if they don't know it
for themselves yet
so there's power but not not more than
there's just there's just the power of
life itself and you know everybody is an
expression of that although they may not
know it yet
everybody so this is
your transcend conventional self-esteem
and it doesn't mean you lose your sense
of worth it shifts into something much
deeper if you think the world is full of
evil people you will meet many evil
people
and in other words unconscious people
and even people who are on the break or
who are halfway between constant
unconscious when you come together with
them your belief will pull them into
unconsciousness
and that's Karma so karma is
the complete absence of
conscious presence and so it's it's
automatic it plays itself out
and time does not free you of karma that
is a
misperception that if you always have
enough time eventually you can become
free of karma karma reduce itself and
repeats itself but it's it's a wheel
and so
the only thing that can free you of
karma is the arising of presence and why
how is it that for us some person
presence right I don't I cannot tell you
why
I only know that at any point
in the wheel of karma presence can come
in it can happen to
this it can happen to a criminal in
prison condemned to death
it can happen to somebody who's never
heard of anything spiritual
it can happen to somebody who's been
meditating for 30 years or not happened
to sustained person who has been
meditating for 30 years so
in your own life I can see from what
you're saying that presence has already
I can sense that presence has already
come into your life
and presence frees you from karma not
all at once
Karma has an enormous momentum meaning
the patterns in yourself the thought
patterns the emotional patterns the
reactive patterns there's enormous
momentum behind that
but as presence arises
gradually
comma diminishes
in its the energy behind it diminishes
and gradually you experience
of fading out
of those patterns they become weaker
you're no longer completely in the grip
of those patterns
so as presence arises
there's a gradual fading out of karma
not that it matters that much anymore
because once you are present
you can as we the previous questioner
said
when we were talking about certain
thoughts still arising certain negative
thoughts that's still part of the karma
the old patterns the unconscious habit
patterns inherited
they still arise but it's no longer
problematic and
they no longer cause the suffering that
they would have caused before because
they are seen in the light of awareness
so the light of awareness arises and in
the light of awareness the patterns no
longer dominate your life they no longer
run your life
and if occasionally it happens and the
patterns do take over then after a
little while you presence returns and
say oh well there it was again
pain body is part of karma
your birth may be strong in some people
not so strong in others
and so as presence arises you are freed
from
Karma
it has and then you have another
completely different Factor coming into
your life
and so for example for a person to
become free of collective Karma
you need to considerable amount of
presence for that to come in to remove
and it then will remove you in one way
or another either internally you find
yourself completely free you might still
live in a violent Society but internally
you would be free there is such a there
is a possibility you can have a holy man
or woman living surrounded by violence
it's possible it's rare but possible
all very often it happens that life
removes you
out of there and you find yourself
somewhere else
so let's say vast Collective karma for
example
in the case of let's say do you have the
Taliban there you have
all kinds of unconscious movements you
had Soviet communism you had national
socialism in Germany and for a person
being born into that
and not being drawn into that
unconsciousness requires considerable
presence
so not that many people for example in
Germany had when Hitler came to power
not many people were able to remove
themselves somewhere some artists some
writers they they left they could see
what was happening and they they were
strong enough not to be identified with
a collective when there had been a
tradition of obedience to Authority for
hundreds of years a tradition of
following your leader and so on to to
take yourself out of that Collective
Karma requires considerable presence but
some people had it
so
it is our destiny then to
go beyond Karma by being the receptacles
for presence
all you can do
to be helpful in this world and help
others is those people that you come
into contact with
you may everybody in this
who is Awakening will find that sooner
or later they become a kind of teacher
to others and what a spiritual teacher
does the teacher points out the
possibility of Awakening out of
identification with unconscious patterns
which means the spiritual teacher
teaches you to go beyond Karma the usual
mistake or dysfunctional way to of
living unconscious way
is as I've mentioned before is devaluing
the present moment and all the valuing
the next moment
ego lives
always with reference to past and future
the mentally are always somewhere else
instead of giving fullest attention to
this because this is the most valuable
moment
why because it's the only one the
present moment give your fullest
attention to this moment because
it's not true that the next moment is
more significant
because it never comes
so there is a way of being totally
present in the planning for the neck for
the future it's all little things
and evenly whoever if you're the pope or
the president of a huge corporation or
the president of a country but still the
same
the present moment
in its richness
is usually overlooked
because you're looking for something
more significant
it's not it's it's fine to achieve
things especially if they are beneficial
but for Humanity and the totality on the
planet
it's lovely to have that
but they don't even that doesn't make up
your identity the more you honor the
Small Things
the more likely it is that you'll
experience
more good things in the so-called future
because you have such a good
relationship with the present the
Gratitude isn't an underlying
the State of Consciousness which is
giving your fullest attention and
honoring what is
the the power to manifest is in
experiencing
the
[Music]
fullness
of the present moment the
undifferentiated fullness
so
when you don't complain about not only
not other people but also about your
life
and you can't be a victim anymore I is
the light of Consciousness in which
these feelings are being experienced
right now the victim
is a is a huge a huge prison it's not it
is not who you are and remember
thanks for everything
[Music]
I have no complaint whatsoever
saw this this wonderful Stillness here
and let's
acknowledge it
the power is not just in you it's all
around you the Transcendence of thinking
means the Transcendence of the egoic
Mind
it means that
you are able
to
spend part of your time
relatively free of compulsive thinking
certainly free of self-serving thinking
and destructive thinking that
continuously creates unhappiness for
yourself and the people around you
how many people lived in the compulsive
narrative in your mind that for many
people is very negative constantly
critical constantly complaining never at
ease with what is there's always
something wrong fault finding because
the ego grows through the constant
opposition
constant antagonism
never it is
always looking for the next thing to
complain about
and its strengthens the ego itself the
it the more you complain oh
offended is a new version these days
it's very popular on the internet
very very offended
outrageous how dare you
there are thousands or hundreds of
thousands that you go on every day they
look on their screen waiting for the
next scene to be offended by
and the ego loves it
and for many of them it's the only way
they can inflate their ego by sitting on
the screen and sending out tweets
the Transcendent of thinking is not
and any kind of regressive movement
we are not regressing to the state of
somebody who is whose mind is relatively
undeveloped
and who does not have a problem with
egoic thinking because there's very
little going on in their minds
what used to be called
before it became Politically Incorrect
idiot
or fool
uh
the fool was
they were always you could see a happy
fools there
they they don't there's not enough
thinking to rank them unhappy so there's
they are below egoic thinking
in the medieval times every village had
at least one village idiot or fool and
they were Norm was accepted essential
part of the community
uh
and even the Royal courts had a fool
very important figure
although that figure probably was just
pretending to be a fool and that was one
of the most sometimes very influential
position in the Royal Court
but also one of the most dangerous jobs
you could have
because you could lose your hand at any
moment but only the fool was able to
tell the king or queen what was wrong no
by making make it into a funny story
but the fool is more deeply connected
as we know wrong from mythology
the fool is more deeply connected with
the source still hasn't gone as far out
as a normally developed human he's more
simple
he a fool for example a relatively
speaking is a simpleton it's like The
Hobbit in Lord of the Rings
the The Hobbit
The Hobbit is a simple guy
um
doesn't should something in complex
terms loves the simple things of Life
loves eating and enjoyment
but why the fool has to go on this
important mission that nobody else can
carry out
that's a mythological motive that's
often the case because the fool is has a
connectedness still with source that the
more developed humans don't have
similar motive in Forrest Gump the movie
the food does great things this guy for
his company but he's
uh because he's and life always supports
him if he watch the movie again he
always he he saves people in the war he
does heroic things but he doesn't claim
credit because he doesn't have much of
an ego yet
and all his life gives him the next
thing and the next thing
supports him
but we don't want to go there when I say
cessation of thinking I'm not talking
about regressing to this to the stage it
is the pre-thinking stage
of humanity I'm thinking about Rising
above
pointing to the possibility of rising
above thinking
so you stop thinking
which is normally associated with
the diminishment of consciousness
and Transcendence of thinking is an
intensification of Consciousness turning
up the light this is why the term
attention and alertness those terms are
extremely important
they're also used in Zen very frequently
the Zen teachings could be described if
you wanted to summarize then
uh is what just because you can just say
simple things like pay attention
there was one then teacher who would
whenever they asked him a question to
explain Zen
he was became quite famous
he we would always raise his finger
please explain Zen to us
what is saying I haven't quite
understood yet
[Music]
he was calling people to attention now
this attention there's a state of
attention that sometimes people
experience when they engaged in
dangerous activity you can climb a
mountain
do you think you're do you think you're
doing much thinking when you're just
hanging on this wall no you can't you
have to be absolutely present in that
moment you have transcended thinking and
the situation has forced you is forcing
you into complete presence this highest
degree of alertness
without it you slip and you're gone
and so this High degree of Learners
however has no has no tension in it in
this in the case of somebody practicing
the dangerous spot yes there's physical
tension but the the state itself has no
tension in it and you do not need to
engage in a dangerous activity in order
to
enter that state we are entering it here
because even as I talk about it
thank you
I hope
well I don't really hope anything but I
I trust that
as I speak about it
is
simultaneously to listening to it you
can
verify in yourself this state of
attention which is a state of very high
alertness but there's no tension in it
it's not the alertness that is sometimes
goes with fear then you go but it's not
that's really a contraction of the
entire body
it's not really alertness
so that's not it it's a very it's a
relaxed alertness
in it
coming together
and it's it's that
if you I just also mentioned the other
day when you first look at something for
the first few seconds
a new Vista a new landscape you enter a
room or you step out of a room into the
open or whatever it is or suddenly
something new comes into your field of
into your perceptual field in the first
two or three seconds you you don't know
what it is you have to First Take it in
there's a moment of a large presence in
this but usually you're only aware of
the sense perception you're not aware of
the background of the alert presence
itself
but you can be aware of the alert
presence itself as you take it in
and that's the key
so you're not just alertly present
you're aware of the field of alert
presence in yourself so to speak as
yourself
and the awareness
of it and it are the same thing
cessation of thinking
now
you can try it let's
even now I would suggest that as I'm
speaking
you may find you may not know this
yet
in the moments when I'm not speaking
like now
and now
if you're alert you're not thinking
you're just present
and now
there's just an alert field of presence
so
some of you
may not be able yet to be totally free
of thinking but I believe that most
people are able to feel better they have
short gaps of north or pure awareness or
no thought just to show
and then you look around
in that moment
your whole
your personal sense of self has receded
in the moment of pure presence which is
just this
you have no memories and you have no
expectations for future yeah because you
have no thought
but you're not you haven't fallen asleep
you're very awake
in that moment you're not a person
anymore
what are you
just a field of Consciousness conscious
presence something has
emerged from within you
and has taken place of the person
is still there it's just gone receded
if the only thing you
achieve in life
is this
that you are able to
become be free of compulsive and
addictive thinking if you're able to
almost one could say to choose
not to think when there's nothing in
particular to think about
when it can just be present
so in other words
if you can step out of thinking into
aware presence that alert space
then
that is the greatest thing you could
achieve in this lifetime that any human
could achieve in this lifetime and yet
there's nobody left to say I have
achieved it that's the problem for the
ego the ego would love to say oh I have
achieved the state of of presence thank
you
so it's not an achievement I'm just
saying it's an achievement but it's not
really
because you didn't do it you got out of
the way and then it happened you know
that
look into that
I'm rarely content or grateful
that's interesting it's very good self
observation too
I'm not content at this moment I'm not
content
my thinking is so negative another good
piece of knowledge my thinking is
negative at this moment what are the
thoughts that are going through my head
so if you apply the awareness that is
already there hiding behind all these
things
if you apply the awareness
to the present moment when these things
arise
defensiveness
what is low self-esteem it's something
that you
tell yourself about yourself in your
mind is certain repetitive thoughts
that the voice in the head
tells you
those are this is self and low
self-esteem you there might be certain
emotions that go with it emotionally
but really those bases for low
self-esteem is something you tell
yourself about your low words
it's thoughts
now
it's not already knows that she has low
self-esteem
and if she can know that she has low
self-esteem in the moment of the low
self-esteem arising as thoughts
she can recognize them as thoughts and
not necessarily true thoughts arising
repetitive thoughts that condition
thoughts perhaps this road self-esteem
might have started in childhood it often
happens to people whose parents are very
critical or parents tell them you're
never good enough it this can be one
reason
so it might have started there it's a
conditioned way of thinking conditioned
thoughts now the awareness that's
already there in the questioner
would need to be there in the moment of
those things arising and then you can
see when these thoughts arise you
recognize them as thoughts that are
rising and you're no longer completely
trapped in what these thoughts are
saying
in other words to use an analogy that we
used not long ago
you can your sense of being is not in
the thought anymore it's in the
awareness of the thought in other words
if you look at the sky
the vast Sky daytime at this time let's
look at a daytime Sky the vasts the
vastness of that the huge expansiveness
of the sky is awareness in this analogy
and clouds that come our thoughts
so when the clouds come why can't I
never do anything right why are other
people's most successful than me or I'm
not good at this when these thoughts
come instead of being drawn into those
clouds
and then the clouds get bigger and
bigger
you remain the sky
and allow the clouds to pass and then to
pass away
and that means you begin to no longer
you're no longer feeding conditioned
thinking and you are separating who you
are you're taking your identity out of
thinking
thinking for a while has a chiller
momentums old patterns will come again
and again but you're no longer renewing
them you're no longer feeding them by
how do you feed them by identifying with
every thought that comes there's a self
in it it's in so you separate yes you
are the awareness behind the thought
same applies to any kind of negative
thinking
you recognize it as
automatic
it arises and it's a thought
so but you are the awareness that knows
that this is a negative thought pattern
and if that can grow because it's
already there to some extent
if that grows which means deepens
then those condition patterns will
diminish they get transmuted
foreign
so
another one point here mentioned I get
defensive easily
defensive can happen happens very very
quickly in in human interactions the
defensiveness can come up so quickly
it's an automatic pattern
and you may only know it afterwards or
that was defensiveness again uh
and defensiveness isn't of course these
are all ego ways of the ego to protect
itself ego being the Mind Made itself
defensiveness will will just come up
with any
any lie just to keep its ego identity
intact so it'll come up with anything uh
just to it's automatic
so
you can of Course in Miracles as analyze
lovely saying which is uh whenever you
become defensive about anything
know that you have identified with an
illusion you have identified yourself
with an illusion
that's interesting
is that true let's say
you say that
the distance from here to the Moon is
uh
I think in kilometers it's like 350 000
or so kilometers
and that the light takes just over one
second
to travel from the Moon to the Earth
and you know that for a fact well I know
that I haven't verified it myself but it
seems to be true
and somebody else says no that's
completely untrue
it actually takes one minute
it does
now this is just a difference of opinion
or Viewpoint and of course you know very
well that the other person is wrong now
if you if you say no that's not right is
that defensiveness
well it depends how you say it the
question is are you identified with your
mind which has this position which
happens to be true but are you
identified
with that mental position in other words
is it do you derive your sense of self
from thought
if you identified with you will get
angry and defensive about the other
person who is so completely wrong and
you might say things like well if you
know that person well you always doubt
me why do you always doubt me you never
believe what I say do you
that's called defensiveness and that's
the ego trying to protect yourself and
then the cause and Miracle thing applies
know that when you become defensive
about anything know that you've
identified with yourself with an
illusion the illusion is not
that it takes one second for the light
from the Moon to travel to the Earth
it's not what the illusion is the
illusion is that you identified with a
thought
with a mind pattern and so you are
strengthening an illusory identity
[Laughter]
by identifying by strengthening the
mental position of me my mental position
that's unconscious
so this is how just a difference of
opinion can degenerate into
huge conflict just a small difference of
opinion because the ego becomes
defensive so that requires
alertness on your part so that you know
when it arises oh so whenever you become
defensive
so without ego the same conversation
would go no it takes one minute I know
that for a fact the other person says
it takes one second I don't think it
takes a minute uh well no you're wrong
it takes one second okay
well we'll leave it at that then I think
it's a second and you think it's a
minute
end of the story
that would be without without
defensiveness or ego okay and then you
can go on on off where everybody goes on
the internet
and that would definitely solve it
and in extreme forms of egoic
unconsciousness you will say what it
says in Wikipedia is wrong
oh
they didn't get it right
that may bring me to another question or
just to to end on this question the key
is your awareness
so that that deepens then all those
patterns that you mention
will weaken
uh and there's already a considerable
amount of awareness in this person the
questioner the awareness of course isn't
the person but it's deeper in the person
the thing is to apply the awareness to
the present moment when things arise not
in some abstract way I am a defensive
person will I ever become a person who
is not negative
I can't get rid of my negative patterns
I'm I'm so negative though it doesn't
matter like this moment is what matters
so just apply your awareness to this
moment you can't change things into
mental constructs how can I change
myself I don't want to be that kind of a
person anymore look at it
to this moment this is where you apply
presence
as I sometimes call it I haven't used
that expression in a while the sort of
presence that cuts through time and you
go
until you apply it to this so you need
to realize most humans have this inbuilt
dysfunction
they cannot acknowledge the present
moment
unconsciously they regard the next
moment with if it's a minute from now
or an hour from now or two years from
now always regarded as more important
whenever you are impatient trying to get
somewhere waiting for something
impatiently what's the next thing I have
to do and I have to do that and you're
pulled in all kinds of directions what's
now oh now I have to do that and that
and that and there's always the pull to
the what's the next thing
uh
that is I call that sometimes
you lose yourself in doing
is necessary obviously you need to do
but to lose yourself in continuous doing
is a serious dysfunction but it's so
normal that nobody realizes it so what
if you lose yourself in the doing
there's always another and this is how
stress arises
but stress is the gap in the gap between
now
and
later the projected then now and then in
that Gap arises this stress arises so
the mental projection towards future
creates the stresses between you where
I'm here but I want to be there and for
many humans that is their predominant
State they are always they are here but
they don't they really want to be there
either they're in space or time
It's amazing And even you Awakening
beings
may still
sometimes or often
find yourself in that state where you'd
suddenly realize that the whole day
you've been stressed about this that and
that and that is the world has to make
so many demands upon you you need to
deal with this and this and this
Amplified by the gadgets that we now use
which is an amplification of the
dysfunction through this
uh and you lose yourself in the doing
you become completely
un-centered and and
basically lost the many even it happens
even to Children already at an early age
these days
and many children are suffering from
attention deficit disorder and so on
which means that their mind is being
pulled always away from the present
moment
so lost in doing
lost in doing
really comes back to
lost in thinking
thinking underlies doing so you're lost
in your thoughts
about the world
and then you you engage in all kinds of
activities propelled by
thought that I know I need to do this
now I need to do that
so the basic condition still from most
humans on the planet
so Prime fundamentally yes they are lost
in doing they lose themselves into but
basically it means they are lost in
their mind in the movement of thought
you identify them they identify with
every thought that arises in this many
thoughts are about future
or the past not that many thoughts about
the present moment
and if they are about the present moment
then it is an interpretation of the
present moment that is completely
determined and colored by your past
conditioning
so very interesting
to observe in oneself
this tendency
to deny
devalue
disregard reduce the present moment to a
means to an end it's always the means to
an end but it's another
recognized for what it is in itself
and often it is not it is more than a
means to an end form many humans
this is a very dysfunctional way of
being
for many humans the present moment is
actually regarded unconsciously as an
obstacle that they need to get Beyond
this
continuous underlying unease
and what's the next thing that is going
to go wrong I know it's going to happen
lost lost in the mind lost in thought
there was an Indian teacher who
described the essential human condition
as lost in thought and of course that's
how it is this is then this movement of
thought
gives you your sense of identity then
the the unease the the uneasy narrative
the problematic Narrative of me and my
life I have to think about this when I
wake up in the middle of the night
and I carry this heavy burden of my
problematic life for many humans their
identity is unconsciously regarded as a
problem to be solved
I am a problem that I'm looking for a
solution
to this problem that I am
and of course then you go to a therapist
now if the therapist is good he might be
able to take you beyond that
depends if he or she is not good then
you get more deeply entranced and 15
years later you are still undergoing
psychoanalysis and finds ever deeper
layers of complexity in your past
and there's no end to it
so
the present moment
is devalue not recognized I regarded
either as a means to an end or an
obstacle
that is the for many humans that is
their predominant state of mental
emotional state
and
as I said the identity is derived from
that so it's the the
the error lies in
identification with thought now the
question arises
who or what is it that identifies with
thought if I am not the story that I
tell myself about who I am
if I am not ultimately that
then who or what am I
and what is it in me that that
identifies with the story what is it
that creates this
sense of identity
that is mostly
exists mostly in a state of unease
or very often discontent
because it cannot
acknowledge the present moment
that is the ego by the way that's what
we call it the the egoic sense of self
there's a very simple spiritual practice
to get you to the realization of who or
what it is that identifies I suggest at
this moment
that
observe yourself internally right now
to see if there's any lingering emotion
in you perhaps from earlier today or an
hour ago or yesterday
or the past two years
or the past
10 years is there any and can you feel
for example if it is an irritation
somewhere is there some kind of anxiety
is there
kind of
heaviness a certain heavy mood
a despondent mode perhaps is it
lingering there
is there anger anger big thing some
residue of Anger from what happened
earlier is that in you and then normally
humans would say
I am angry or they would say
I am anxious I'm fearful
I am
in a bad mood
now there's already a delusion when the
moment you say I am angry or I am
anxious
that indicates already that you have
identified with the emotion of anger or
the emotion of
sadness or the emotion of fear
you have identified you equate I with
what arises in your field of
consciousness
so you say I'm angry
it would be more correct to say
there's anger in me right now
it may sound a trivial difference
between saying I am angry and there's
anger in me but there's a significant
difference which goes beyond mere syntax
how you put words together because when
you say I am you equate I with whatever
condition is there in you this applies
to emotion and it also applies to a
thought
when
because anger is often is not just the
anger as emotion the anger also exists
as a angry thoughts and then they they
in they reinforce each other as a
vicious circle when you when they when
you are trapped in irritation or anger
the emotion feeds the thought and the
thought feeds more energy to the emotion
it's a vicious circle
and you don't want to get out of it you
might notice when you
observe an angry person or or despondent
person on anxious person
They Don't Really Want to Be Free of the
anger they don't want their turn if you
suggest it to an angry person you can be
free you will not get a pleasant answer
and you you've seen angry people who
they are in the grip of anger or
irritation they cannot help it then they
shout at you and then they leave the
room and the minute later the door opens
they come back because they're sort of
something else to insult you with
they
are in the grip of it there is a
complete identification with thought and
emotion
they are lost in thought they are Lost
in Emotion but who or what is it that is
lost
if I'm not the thoughts and the emotion
who or what am I
okay
I just asked you to just have a look
inside yourself and see what it is if
there's anything there that's jarring
and doesn't feel good but it's there
and I'm not saying try to get rid of it
no
acknowledge the present moment the
present moment is what is
externally or internally
that's what is but there's a huge
difference now you've already by
recognizing that there is let's say
irritation anger or anxiety in you
an additional
element one dimension has come in
and that I mentioned we could call
awareness
or we could call it presence
and the moment awareness comes in
you are no longer completely identified
with it one could say I sometimes
describe it as let's say there's the
anger
and as your awareness of the anger comes
in
there's a little bit of space around it
let's see awareness the awareness knows
that there's anger
the anger may still be there it may not
immediately disappear but the awareness
knows it's there
or whatever else it may be the arising
of awareness is spiritual awakening
the disidentification that happens
when awareness arises
that is
the spiritual awakening or the arising
of the Transcendent dimension of
Consciousness Transcendent because it
transcends
who
or what you are as a person there's no
need to demand the external conditions
should be perfect so that you can become
still
in fact it's sometimes the case that
it's precisely
when external conditions
are seemingly unhelpful
that can sometimes be a greater
opportunity
to find that true Stillness
and especially that is the case
when external circumstances
have the appearance
of actually being
a hindrance
something disturbing
something
happening that upsets
the status quo in your life
and those are great opportunities
because then your motivation for going
deeper as you suffer when things happen
in your external life
that quote unquote should not be
happening
then you
begin to suffer and as you suffer the
motivation eventually arises
of going deeper of finding the place
where there is no suffering
and you could still suffer a little bit
on the external level of your life
so sooner or later we find
in our life
that life does things to us
seemingly putting obstacles in our past
seemingly having bad intentions towards
us
we experience
diminishment
in some form
of course the ego says or the egoic self
says
that's terrible
I don't want any diminishment
the management meaning
loss or something
[Music]
that had become part of your sense of
self
it could be loss of
possessions
could be loss of a relationship
loss of a loved one
loss of a healthy body
diminishment of
physical
health
loss of
you know
Persona of what other people think of
you
one day they tell you they're the other
greatest and the next day they tell you
you're awful
diminishment of whatever kind is
abhorrent to the egoic self
there's a beautiful saying I believe it
comes originally I'm not sure but it
doesn't matter where it comes it comes
out of Consciousness so it doesn't
really matter
[Applause]
but I believe it comes originally out of
Sufism
and that is
when the ego weeps for what it has lost
the spirit rejoices for what it has
found
and those people who
there's no Human by the way who does not
experience this
in life several times
sooner or later
the next one comes some people
experience it even very early in life
some children have experienced loss of a
parent of both parents
so diminishment comes
sooner or later
how do you meet it
recognize it when it comes
not as
a monster
or the work of some malevolent deity
or demon that wants to sabotage your
life
but as an opportunity also
now you may not be able to be grateful
for it in the moment of it happening
there would be Perhaps Perhaps too much
to ask
but you will find that
uh later
a year may pass
two years depending on what it is
suddenly realize that it has taken you
deeper into the essence of who you are
because something was removed from you
that you thought you were but it was a
fiction ultimately
you had identified with something that
ultimately is not who you had the
temporary thing
possessions not status great physically
strong body
good looks
a relationship
and they need a retrospectively
very often you should be able to be
grateful for the loss for the
diminishment because it drove you deeper
it brought out the essence of
who you are Beyond
any form now it does not do that to all
humans
it's for everybody the management is
only a potential deepening the the
possibility is there
many many humans are not able
to use it because nobody has told them
the knowledge this kind of spiritual
knowledge is still very limited it is
not part
of mainstream culture people are dying
every day
without having any true assistance
people who are approaching deaths who
are getting old
the our mainstream culture still knows
nothing it's just let's prolong life as
well as long as mostly even if it's
totally pointless and it creates a lot
of suffering let's just because we don't
know what to do with this
that's one of the reasons why the
foundation will hopefully be able to
reach
people to use the opportunity of this
greatest diminishment which is death the
greatest when as you approach this
an enormous
opportunity for Spiritual Awakening
realization
but many humans of course miss the
opportunity of that diminishment and
with the result that the ego becomes
even more hardened
through it
or in the words of Brother David
shriveled shriveled up to an even harder
life listing
then either you carry continuous anger
or resentment or despondency for years
which becomes part of your egoic
identity and the ego loves any kind of
identity if it's a miserable one doesn't
matter I'll have it
just give me a strong identity
may I take miserable anytime over being
nobody
so the opportunity of diminishment is
missed often you see when people they're
wealthy people and suddenly something
happens they lose their money
and then they jump out of the window
because the entire sense of self was
associated
with their possessions
there are people who lose their
reputation or you remember of course the
case of Mr Madoff years a few years ago
who
had this scheme fraudulent schemes and
people lost millions or billions of
people who were investing with him on
Wall Street
they lost it was a pyramid it was a
Ponzi scheme I think it's the word
so here just deceiving all these people
and they lost all their money and he had
accumulated billions and then finally it
all collapsed
now he's in prison and his sons couldn't
take it
one one of his sons apparently the sons
didn't know what was going on I don't
know if that's true but
they were also working in his firm in
his company I think believe one died of
cancer soon after and the other
committed suicide
would have been a great opportunity if
only somebody had told them you've lost
your money you've lost your reputation
is a great opportunity
[Music]
find yourself the opening is there
but it's just lack of information nobody
told them
I hadn't actually thought of this until
this moment because we had want to bring
the the teaching to places where it
otherwise would not be
go
not reach and I just thought of Wall
Street
thank you
we will donate books and CDs to both
[Applause]
so we'll have to call Goldman Sachs
tomorrow
see if they agree
now they won't be very interested
perhaps at the moment
but they may become interested in the
future
[Music]
just wait
so you have already I believe everybody
here
has already experienced some forms of
diminishment
to use that word
through the physical form
the psychological me entity and for many
the reason why you're here is because
you've gone through that
and it has deepened you
in the collapse of a relationship you
don't even have don't have to be married
but you have a relationship
doesn't go well
it ends it's a little death
can be painful it leaves a little
hole in you it takes it seemingly rips
something out of you and for quite a
while you feel it
it's not pleasant
but there too is an opportunity
so when the ego weeps for what it has
lost
oh dear
there's so terrible I'll tell you what
happened
and I'll tell myself what happened even
if nobody's listening
[Music]
okay
I can't take anymore of this I just
can't take this it's just too much
what's the point of it all just
completely of course
it's good to act out the the ego
sometimes because then you can actually
see it is like a reflection in the
mirror because it's funny because you
remember everybody knows familiar with
that in some way and that's why it
becomes funny
I I'm learning from Marianne yesterday
because she has other ways of acting out
the ego
it's a little bit more
feminine but I can try that too
it may look a little weird when I do it
you know
[Music]
but it's there's a lot in it that
doesn't really need to be explained in
words just this simple gesture
implies a self-image to look at yourself
through a self-image with me
be grateful for whatever
you experience of this moment is and if
you cannot be grateful
at least allow it to be
because
it already is
you might as well
now if you did this little thing it
sounds very little and it is very little
allowing your experience of this moment
to be the way it is
just this little thing would remove
oh well it's hard to put it in
percentage terms let's say 95 percent of
the suffering from your life
I don't know about the rest of five
percent we'll get to that sometime
that would already remove a gigantic
chunk of unhappiness
in whatever form
unhappiness is the most generic term one
could use the Buddha called it suffering
and so for the next six months then
that obviously is one of the practices
not to internally resist your experience
of this moment
now of course
thank you
many times
[Music]
possibly you'll forget that
and that's fine
the moment you realize that you forgot
it
it's there again and then you can accept
the experience of this moment as the
unhappiness that is arising in you
because you forgot
to accept your experience of this moment
and so you feel this unhappiness arising
in you and you say where does that come
from
oh
I forgot to accept my experience of this
moment
and then say you accept the unhappiness
and the weird thing with unhappiness is
when you completely accept the
unhappiness it cannot survive very long
it doesn't like it cannot actually
co-exist
with acceptance
so the weird thing that arises that
you say something like
okay I'm unhappy it's okay I don't mind
being unhappy
foreign
it's not supposed to happen
the kind of the unauthiness can just
can't survive for very long were the
acceptance
even the acceptance of unhappiness not
indulging in unhappiness
but the acceptance not the acceptance of
unhappiness
it presupposes that there's an awareness
there that knows that you're unhappy
now that might sound like something
very natural but it isn't
because
the most unhappy people and they're
still millions and of course they have
reasons for being unhappy yes
the
and it's not necessarily the people who
you'd think would have the the most
powerful reasons for being unhappy it's
often those who you would think well
they
there are many millions you have it
worse than they but these are more happy
than those that's often the case
it's all the unhappiness
is
something that when it's recognized as
unhappiness and accepted
something happens to it it begins to
dissolve
but the really unhappy people are so
identified with the unhappiness which is
a combination of
certain
recurring thoughts in your head a
certain narrative
that is not pleasant
whether it is about
my life whether the narrative says
my life or Dreadful thing in my life
why did it all go so wrong so wrong
wrong
and now I still have to that's it's
nothing I can do and at least I'm
or whether the narratives about somebody
else
The Narrative maybe about something that
hasn't happened yet and it goes on and
on
or something that happened in the
distant past or not so distant past
there so there's a narrative and then
the emotions that are reflection of the
narrative The Narrative is thoughts
certain types of thoughts
the certain thought that have a certain
frequency
and and then that awakens the emotional
frequency because the body thinks the
narrative in your mind is a reality that
is the reality that you're experiencing
so you the body reacts with an emotion
it's simple it's simple example at night
you can't sleep because you're extremely
worried about what's going to happen to
you
or somebody close to you
[Music]
or even the world
and
it all sounds very critical
is a crisis in your head
not outside outside your head there's a
pillow
and there's a
a blanket or even something big and
fluffy and soft down
duvet
[Music]
and there's no unhappiness there and if
you look around the bedroom also where's
the unhappiness
art is okay it's not unhappy
it's all happening here
[Music]
and then the body since that Israel the
critical reality that you inhabit you
are there is a crisis in your life the
body doesn't know the difference between
what's actually happening and what's
happening in your head what's happening
in your head is
taken to be the absolute reality
and then you experience the emotion that
goes with that kind of narrative and so
there's no awareness and when you're
trapped in that you don't even really
know that you are unhappy because you
are the unhappiness
the unhappiness has become your identity
so when you become the unhappiness
you don't even know that you're all soft
let's use the Buddhist term suffering
when you are in this deep suffering you
don't even know you're suffering because
the suffering is a gigantic huge chunk
part of your dead sense of self
you are a suffering entity
and as
all therapists know that
once the patient or the client or
whatever they call the people that come
to them according to their school the
they reach a point where there's a
possibility of going beyond the
deep-seated patterns unconscious
patterns and then there's a huge
resistance very often
because the person is afraid of losing a
very important
piece of their identity and sometimes
it's the most important part of the
identity if they have lived with an
unhappy sense of self for years and
perhaps even decades
they don't want to let go and again they
don't know that consciously they they
never say I do not want to let go but if
they could say that then that means
there's already some awareness so
lack of awareness lack of presence that
is the unawakened state
that still unfortunately millions of
humans are trapped in that
but the moment you know you recognize
your inner state
that that means there is an awareness
which is there is another dimension of
Consciousness that has emerged in you
through you
a deeper dimension of Consciousness that
is not the conditioned thinking
that's what we can call it awareness we
can call it presence you can call it
the unconditioned consciousness
and
then the beginning of Freedom around the
possibility of Freedom arises and since
it's from there that you recognize your
inner states as they arise from there
that you recognize
your unhappiness and say oh you can like
you can feel the unhappiness
but the moment you become aware of
suffering on happiness
in you
you're no longer feeding it with your
thoughts
as long as you're not aware you're
feeding it there's a vicious circle
you're feeding it with your thoughts
with your narrative and you're trapped
in the Vicious Circle your narrative
creates more unhappiness the unhappiness
creates more thought
and you're trapped in that
so for the next six months and and
hopefully Beyond because it's much
more pleasant way to live
you make it your practice to be aware of
your inner states and meaning
no matter what situation arises in your
life whether it's the little things big
things
difficult situations difficult people
challenges problems
because the next six months are not
going to be free of challenges and
problems
so whatever it is
realize that the primary factor
in any situation
is your inner state
because that determines how you respond
so no matter what it is your primary
responsibility is
to be aware of what goes on inside you
and
that means whatever arises in your life
is actually to be used in your practice
so that you do not
become
dependent on what's going on
externally in your life so your inner
State gradually is no longer
determined perhaps still a little bit
yes
but not to completely determined by our
events people situations and so on
inner Freedom arises that's Awakening
how you how you responded and that
if you I have to we can use
the two words react respond the way I
use them is react means
it's a comically determined reaction
you you you you act you react out of the
conditioning of your mental emotional
field
response implies that you are present
and
your action is no longer determined by
the mental emotional the conditioning of
the person there is a higher
intelligence one could say or I I call I
call it wisdom but in other words
there's a high intelligence it can then
operate in your daily life
a higher intelligence which we could
call Western so it's not the
conventional intelligence that you can
measure in IQ tests
that's a very limited version of
intelligence there's a higher
intelligence that comes in through
presence
that deals more intelligently with any
situation that arises in your life
that's that's the only possible way of
dealing intelligently is by
um
dealing with the situation through
presence
especially important of course in human
relationships
it's so much unconsciousness that
happens in the interaction between human
beings
between two human beings and larger
numbers of human beings and then groups
of your collectives of your millions of
human beings here and another million
there and there
or this you can see when you look at
politics and
Affairs and so what's happening in the
world
there's very little intelligence the way
they deal with things
and you would be you're amazed how can
they be so short-sighted and ultimately
have to use a simple word
stupid
but these people have degrees they have
University degrees
how can they be so stupid
because well they only activate it if a
very very limited version of
intelligence that you can measure in IQ
tests
that's not enough
you you I'm sorry I don't want to
confront anybody who has a very high IQ
uh or is a member of this there's an
organization called menza I believe so
if you have a very IQ you can be a
member of that and that's good for your
identity of course
so I don't want to take anything away
from you but
the there is that is what real
intelligence it's sort of yes it is a
form of intelligence but it's a
relatively low form of intelligence a
much higher intelligence comes in
through presence and that is lacking
in the world there are occasionally you
see
the very rarely you see a politician
actually you can see oh this person has
some real intelligence and insights and
it's usually not the people who are
running things it's if it's a politician
it's usually somebody who's been pushed
to the periphery of politics and from
there he used to see comments on the
under the stupidity of what's happening
in the wild I've observed it it's in
different countries to a similar
phenomenon they are okay there are a few
people here and there who like you can
see clearly
where we are going and what we're doing
it it's crazy
because there is a lack of true this
higher intelligence that is beyond the
egoic mind
and um
well
at the moment it doesn't look good
because we're going one now
I was going to use that weird expression
about the hand basket again
[Laughter]
so you can see it now it's important
when you look at the state of the world
um it's important that
you don't you do not enter a reactive
mode because that will draw you into
unconsciousness
if you also if you watch too much
television or current affairs
you will be drawn into most likely
unconsciousness
unless you watch it as an uh
you watch it as
an anthropological study of
how misguided Humanity can be
so you need to stay present while you
look at all this
and see what's happening question may
arise
shouldn't I be doing something to well
there may be something you can do
bring some sanity into this world
perhaps to
saying something
speaking out pointing out something not
clear not creating enemies
if you see people that do you
are deluded in what they say or do
don't make them into enemies and to
track them and say you are totally crazy
no it's the
it may be that the
what they
what they do
maybe and probably is
[Music]
dysfunctional and stupid
or the the opinions they hold maybe the
extremely misguided and irrational
so you can you can
address the opinions that they hold
their mental positions and point out
the irrationality and so on without
making the people who hold their opinion
into enemies
so don't equate
the mental positions that people hold
with who they essentially are
you can speak out maybe you can post
something on one of the many platforms
that are available something there that
is saying rather than insane
but it may
perhaps you can post something that
points out the insanity of it all
some people do that
so that's a good thing
now because some people makes suddenly
say oh yes that's true
foreign
so high intelligence comes in
and that can then deal with situations
and that's the end of karma what
humanity is doing now collectively is
uh
Karma playing itself out
the movement of unconsciousness
and so as we mentioned yesterday with
reference to individuals
you remember we talked about
responsibility I had you can you hold a
person responsible for what they do if
they are unconscious
we talked about that yesterday if they
are in the grip of their their mental
emotional conditioning
that is part of that's a Karma can you
hold a karmic formation
person
can you hold a karmic formation
responsible for what they do
not really
so there's a deep wisdom in what Jesus
said forgive them for they know not what
they do forgiveness means the
realization that they are not
responsible they can but I cannot do
otherwise
but we also in this also applies to the
collective
what all the politicians are doing and
so on
they don't they don't don't know any
better they are in the grip of
egoic reactivity and short-sightedness
it comes with it and so on
but as as it is the case with
individuals
although they may not be and are not
cannot be held responsible and yet
they have to suffer
the call the consequences of their
unconscious this is how humans
ultimately awaken they are not
responsible they still have to they
create suffering for themselves and
others
and through the suffering that true
created
through the uncle by the unconsciousness
an Awakening happens still in other
words the ego
yeah
is necessary for the Awakening to happen
the ego ultimately self-destructs
it has built into it a self-destruct
function
that is Ultimate wisdom
so that's
also applies to the collective
already if you look at the
20th century the wars that happened and
the internal conflicts in countries it
happens the countless Millions upon
Millions killed by other humans what
they did the terrible suffering
this is all the movement of
unconsciousness there they can't they
don't know what they do and then they
solve Humanity suffers and suffers and
suffers through the suffering gradually
an Awakening happens
so the the the ego's dysfunction creates
suffering and ultimately the suffering
acts as an awakener
it's just a question of how much longer
is the suffering going to go and what's
the next stage you may ask in the
on the scale of collective suffering
I don't know but it doesn't look good at
the moment
but you are here to represent
to embody
the
higher intelligence I mean hopefully you
don't make that into a mental concept
I embody the higher intelligence
[Music]
oh it is true but it should not become a
mental concept that you identify with
and so the sanity you you embody the
sanity
in a world that is still predominantly
one has to say insane in many ways
not all of it is insane but a lot of it
some important parts are insane
so let's see what the
whatever comes is
it may be bad from from
the lower perspective doesn't look good
but ultimately everything that happens
in the service of the evolution of
consciousness
even in your own life and if it applies
in your own life
it also applies to the collective of
humanity adversity can
either he can strengthen the ego
or it can gradually or in some cases
suddenly
dissolve the ego or at least diminish it
it can go either way
and I must agree with you I don't know
whether you literally said it
in perhaps still in the majority of
cases
it strengthens the ego because nobody
knows people don't know
the opportunity that every adversity
represents so why does it happen how
does it strengthen the ego you can see
it sometimes with people who are sick
of people who are disabled to us let's
say I've met disabled people people with
physical disabilities for example
and in some cases
they are very they're really angry with
the world and bitter because look at
what happened to me they say why do I
can't move anymore I've been Afflicted
with this what have I done
to deserve this and these are
questions that are still there the
justifiable questions the uh the
question what what have I done to
deserve why has the world or whatever
they say go to the world the universe or
whoever they've done this to me while
and then they become
bitter and angry and the ego becomes
more and more rigid and hardened and uh
[Music]
oh Lord
and so that is one way it could go and
then I have met people with disabilities
who through their disability
at some point whether through a
spiritual teaching and in some cases
never come into contact with any
spiritual teaching it just happened that
at some moment they realized intuitively
that all the suffering
was generated in the school resistance
and then the resistance to the is-ness
of their life this moment
they were able to let go because perhaps
the suffering was getting too much
something happened something clicked
inside
or even if it didn't happen completely
they were able to have moments of
uh inner peace
an inner peace that is not caused by an
external condition
an inner peace that seems to be in
control contradiction to an external
condition so that they would survive How
could a person who is suffering this
feels so peaceful and so
um
also that applies to people who are
approaching the end of their lifespan
because they have some
illness and they have been to the doctor
and the doctor says you have six months
or one year
and
so and suddenly
something Inland opens up and all that
remains is
that the person already dies there's no
more future and All That Remains is the
present moment and the the aware space
so I've had the privilege of working
with when I was still seeing individuals
where the two or three people to whom
that happened
and they became luminous beings in the
last few
weeks or months of their lives and
became just
there was no there wasn't I couldn't see
there was any person left there was only
a space of conscious presence left
just wonderful as if they had just come
into this world
so they came and then they came to me
and then still asking questions very
profound questions wanting to understand
what happened and it was beautiful
so this can happen it can happen
collectively to people who have
Google through Warfare and in countries
or become refugees they lose everything
and again it can go either way
uh whenever there's any great loss in
your life that again an opportunity
opens up
if if you resist and you regret you
resist the resistance origin the origin
of their existence is a narrative that
forms in your mind
uh that says something about the
situation and about your life and about
other people uh so the narrative forms
in your mind and the narrative is an
unhappy one
and then there's continuous resistance
and non-alignment with the isness of the
present moment now one could ask well
how could somebody who is lost who's
lost their home perhaps even lost love
loved ones
and then they don't know where to go
how could this person be in a state of
alignment with the present moment isn't
that how can how can somebody accept the
unacceptable
except that which in conventional terms
would be regarded as unacceptable how is
that how is that possible
but that's precisely it
if you can accept the unacceptable that
is the sudden the opening and then you
realize
the unacceptable is actually not
unacceptable it is acceptable
and the I was homeless was a period in
my life with not knowing where to what
to live on the network
next day or the next week and
I had already gone into a state of
acceptance so it was a very pleasant
experience but potentially would have
been extremely unpleasant
so not having a home was for me already
something that wasn't not experienced as
something bad but I knew I had to take
some action
eventually to to get a home and so
gradually
something happens I don't want to talk
too much about that
I also mentioned in the
the new ass I believe
um when I was at University there was
the
Stephen Hawkins the physicist who was
confined to a wheelchair who passed away
a few couple of years ago on there it
was
um he would always he wasn't famous at
that time only famous locally in the
University we would always be in the
same dining room having lunch but not
the same table I never we met him was
introduced as well observed him many
times did he better neighboring table
and I said and then I
the one moment when I hold out opened
the door for him he was coming through
on his wheelchair
and I looked into his eyes and I could
see there was no unhappiness in this
world
you have to be careful with
what kind of
shorts
you absorb from the collective
because there's so much unhappiness
in the collective energy field of
humanity
so
it's very easy to get drawn into that
you're not careful
and
participate
in the
suffering of the collective
fear anxiety
anger that's everywhere
it's also very easy to be
affected by
certain
thoughts that can take over your mind
that come from the collective
thoughts and thoughts patterns
anybody who is not
sufficiently present
sufficiently aware
is
susceptible to
uh
being infected
by
certain thoughts
the mind
become lodged in your mind that every
thought is an energy formation
like you could say a little entity
thought gets large in your mind
and attracts Associated thoughts and
becomes a bundle of thoughts
and without awareness
you identify with the thoughts and then
you are in being possessed by certain
thoughts they may be
they may arise from your personal but
very commonly they arise from the
collective
in your personal life
you could develop
some kind of
thought that
of an obsessive nature that occupies
your mind
and you can't get rid of it
um
it could be
the thought of one
directed to one particular person
very very negative thoughts
um even
foreign
level
some people have
you can have a Melody that you can't get
rid of in your mind you can have a whole
day or two days and you can't get rid of
some this thing that's in your mind it
repeats itself again and again
you can have certain assumptions about
this world
like
they may be totally absurd and
irrational or they may be some truth to
it but only there may be an aspect of
the truth
uh
you might think that
um
the most absurd thoughts could be there
you might think that's the uh
the extraterrestrials already here well
there may be but and
every other human is actually an alien
and you just have to look at them
carefully to figure out whether they are
aliens or humans and that good I'm not
excluding the possibility that some
aliens may be here but we are really I'm
talking about obsessive thoughts that
are probably not correct
and then they'd call us your subsequent
perception of reality gets totally
colored by the obsessive thoughts and it
can explain everything
in those terms or the evils of the world
have suddenly one explanation
um
another one that's also in the
collective you can have a thought that
the entire world is divided into
oppressor and oppressed
are you any human being either belongs
to the oppressors
or to the oppressed that was an idea in
communism in economic terms in terms of
Social Power they divided Humanity into
oppressors and oppressed and then they
look at you can look at any human being
he's oppressed he's an oppressor now
thing is
of course oppressors and oppress have
existed
and to some extent in Syria and some
areas still exist
but to take one for one fragment of
trolls because the totality of human
life is much faster than that this is
one aspect
but if you take one aspect that then
occupies your mind because of lack of
awareness you are possessed by a thought
and this all tests the entire world this
is just one example it could give many
examples the entire world is either
either the essential Identity or any any
human being is either they are oppressed
or they are the oppressor no of course
if that is the what the thoughts that
dominate your mind
then obviously you will probably
regard the oppressed as the good ones
and the oppressors is the bad one so
that then that simplifies life
enormously you immediately can decide
who is good and who is bad and you are
probably good
presumably
um even if you if you're an oppressor
traditionally your your you now uh
um recognize your sins and you will
atone for your sins of being an
oppressor and you side with the
oppressed and therefore you become one
of the good people okay
so
we had the same phenomenon in very
extreme form we all know about Soviet
communism we know about
Chinese Maori Tung cultural revolution
quite a crazy time here to be known
national socialism in Germany all these
the evils perpetrated by all these
Collective
delusional systems The Divided people
into good and bad entire groups gave
them an identity
um
I was in Cambodia a few years ago
and visited the
um
the
the death camps of where the cambodians
are it's a small country so not many
people are familiar with the recent
history of Cambodia but they had a
a an extreme Communist Regime and a mad
dictator called Pol Pot
and in that risk extreme Communist
Regime come and Cambodia
experience Dreadful suffering one-third
of the population was
um killed by their own government
because they were the oppressors
and oppressor was anybody who could read
and write because obviously they were
exploiting the peasants
anybody who wear wore glasses
it could would immediately like that's
why the oppressor they would be sent
from the citizen to the countryside to
work on the fields where they didn't
have enough food and most of them
starved
total lack of humanity total like
because of
the entire country was dominated by one
observed and obsessive thought that that
made them made it impossible for them to
relate to any human being as a human
being they relate them through the
conceptualization that they that thought
had created for them they couldn't sense
the humanity the being of the other
human anymore the moment they had
imposed the conceptual identity on them
this is an extreme example of what can
happen to you when you're taken over by
certain thoughts in your mind is not to
mean that of course oppressive
impressive existed and exist but it's
not not the entire explanation them
there are many other facts in this life
but I'm saying all this because
that you need to be very alert so that
your mind is not taken over
by
certain thoughts that are not
um that invade your mind and color your
view of reality
and
there are there are certain irrational
thoughts that are floating around in the
collective at the present time so it's
very easy to for you to absorb some of
them and being possessed by certain
thoughts and maybe it's
so irrational that it's unbelievable but
I'm not giving any examples but you have
to find it out for yourself
with awareness you can
and
be be very careful with observing your
mind
be there as the witness of your mind so
that you don't get taken over by by
certain thoughts that your mind does not
get taken over by certain thoughts and
then you you you
cannot perceive reality anymore as it is
you everything is colored by the veil of
irrational thinking
so
when you
nowadays these things can spread very
quickly and easily these irrational
things in the past they were confined to
either one country or one area in a
particular country
but nowadays certainly the rational
thoughts can go through the entire world
through the technology we have and can
quickly affect millions of humans all
over the world
so in the past you had it as I said
limited let's say the uh the
the hunt for witches in the past are
totally absurd and irrational it's a
mental disease that uh affected certain
countries or areas in certain countries
and this mental disease and uh so there
were some places in in Europe there were
Villages and towns in Europe in the
Middle Ages during that time of
collective insanity
there were almost no women left in in
some villages in Towns at that time if
they're all in the burnt okay or drowned
because they were called as witches
absolute absolute Insanity so don't
underestimate how insane humans can
become
the only
um
antidote that you have against that is
awareness
so that your mind does not get affected
by mental virus
the awareness the awareness is aware of
what your mind is doing so that your
mind does not get occupied by one
particular way of thinking which is
probably irrational anything that's
one-sided
that does not see the
totality of a situation
like oppressant oppressed uh if you
don't see the the many factors that
make up a human being's identity uh so
very be very careful
with what you consume in the media the
the media that brings the news to you be
very careful with what you consume so
that you take do not take on
without knowing it unquestingly certain
ways of looking at the world uh
realize that you're being
homanipulative most of the mainstream
media has become so you need to watch
that if you watching or knowing how
you're being manipulated and there there
the people themselves are being
manipulated too so it's they are in the
grip of unconsciousness and they want to
draw others into unconsciousness so they
are not they're not the evil ones they
just don't know any better you are now
compared to years ago
you went out you are now
definitely more conscious
than you were before
and it could be that in the past
when you were not conscious
you did things that you know now
recognize as
not right
or you inflicted suffering on another
being or other beings
and you can now see it
at the time you didn't know what you
were doing because you were not
conscious enough to act differently
now the fact that the faster feels
guilty means
he or she can see something now that he
or she could not see then
if you were still in the same
Consciousness then you wouldn't be able
to see that that was wrong it's a
you did the right thing by whatever
killing that person I did the right
thing but now you see you have awakened
and then you can see a lot of your past
as
dysfunctional unconscious action
inflicting suffering on yourself and
others virtually every unconscious human
inflicts suffering both on themselves
without knowing it and others they
create their own misery and they make
others miserable that's what unconscious
humans do
and some to a greater degree than others
so guilt can come up as you awaken and
suddenly see how unconscious you were
that can bring up guilt and say because
the guilt says I did that
The Guild says uses the word I
but what does that mean what does it
mean when you say I what is that I who
is I is I the conditioning of your
mental emotional conditioning
or does I have a deeper meaning is who
is I when you think that your mental
emotional conditioning is I
then you aren't deluded your mental
control engaging is not I it is the
mental emotional conditioning in you
it's a false identity there is no real
eye there
the only true I is the I am it is you
are you the the essence of who you are
is consciousness that is the eye
I am that I am that's even this how God
describes himself when in this property
some one of the most profoundest lines
in the Bible
somebody asked God who are you or what's
your name
I am that I am
because your deepest I am is the I am of
the universe
it's not personal
your deepest identity is the identity of
God and of the of the universe this is
the eye that's the only true I so when
you confuse the unconsciousness of your
past which was only
conditioning
which was a reflection of where humanity
is at at its present evolutionary stage
you reflected where humanity is in its
present evolutionary stage that's all
you wear a reflection of the evolving
but or the unevolved
as yet unevolved human consciousness
that's all there is no I in there it's
not that I did that
the unconsciousness the human
unconsciousness did that
if you construct an eye out of a human
unconsciousness that you represented
that is an ego attempt
to manufacture another mind made
identity for yourself because the ego
loves to have a conceptual identity the
ego is conceptual identity in the head
that's me I so and the ego doesn't mind
even if it's a very unhappy conceptual
identity it prefers that to having no
conceptual identity because that's its
end
so the ego will cling to the guilt and
Associate unconscious action in the past
with identity my identity
and that's how how the ego can survive
for years and you can touch it can
torture you for years saying I did that
and it's a terrible feeling that that
you did that you can now see it as so
wrong that was so wrong
but it's ultimately a delusion find the
true I
and then that will free you of that and
then you will naturally forgive yourself
without needing to take an action and
say I must forgive myself that doesn't
really work in the same way that it does
this can also be applied to other humans
you can also do that to other humans
what you do to yourself when you see
what they did
and you can manufacture an identity out
of their unconscious action also and
then say this is who they are this is
who he is who she is it's not it's
unconsciousness playing itself out human
unconsciousness there is no ultimate
identity there but but the Mind likes to
manufacture a conceptual identity not
only for yourself but also for others
so the Mind loves to get indented these
are those evil ones and sometimes you do
it to a whole group of people
those millions of this particular group
of people no matter what they are they
are this is what they are and this is
what they did and this that is who they
are no it's human unconsciousness that's
all
so very careful the same process and
then you cannot forgive them because
you've made an identity for them out of
their unconsciousness and so that's they
are their unconsciousness
and then forgiveness will be very hard
okay I have to try to forgive because
I'm supposed to do that
I have to forgive them for what they did
it's just terrible things but I have to
forgive them
okay I forgive you uh it's not easy yes
the real forgiveness happens when it's
just you realize that ultimately
there's nothing to forgive
and that's true forgiveness there's
nothing to forgive
and forgiveness happens naturally in
this way not not as a conscious thing
that you do but a thing that happens by
itself it falls away the false identity
that you inflicted on yourself or or
another human being or a group of human
beings
let false conceptual identity Falls away
and that is an essential part of
being here as a conscious human being a
conscious human being does not have
resentments anymore because what could
you resent it's only a few
manufacturers due to Identity and this
resentment
so all those things just they fall away
and there's the
the flowering
of Consciousness you need the chance and
you need to challenge yourself if you
want to create something if you want to
bring about some change in this world
you want to make your life your
so-called life better you are looking to
achieve this or to learn this or to
acquire this that's part of being human
we don't deny that
and if you don't want to achieve
anything let's say you have no ambition
whatsoever and say oh it's all pointless
because you don't want to be you don't
want to challenge yourself
then life will challenge you even more
if you don't if you're challenging
yourself would be even to engage in
physical activity and jogging you're
challenging yourself or you're lifting
weights for your challenging the body on
a physical level the only way you can
make the body stronger the physical body
is by making let's put I'll put it like
this is a strange way of putting it but
it's true
you have to make life difficult for your
body
otherwise it doesn't get stronger
well to lift the way it is I mean if you
ask the body would you rather have a
good just to relax or lift his weight
I just want to relax
I don't want to make but don't make my
life more difficult than it needs to be
so I'll just okay you don't get stronger
without the but when you you make life
difficult for the body then more energy
is demanded and more energy comes
flowing in the energy isn't come until
you demand it as a request or demand for
energy because there's a there's a gap
between uh what you want and what at the
moment the body doesn't have enough
energy and suddenly it comes then you
reach a point when an influx of energy
starts then you it's no longer perceived
that the the
you make life difficult for your body
once the Energy starts flowing the body
enjoys this love energy but before the
Energy starts flowing life was difficult
for the body
and so you always you meet always the
the threshold of life gets difficult for
the body and then energy comes in and
then suddenly not even perceived as
difficult anymore and that you may
experience it every day when you start
exercising when I look at you first
thing I would see is your personality or
of course the physical body and the
personality whatever makes up your
personality but if I look more deeply
and not just look but actually sense
your presence I know that beyond your
personality there is an Essence in you
that it is one with the essence in me
and one could describe it as
Consciousness itself the essence of Who
You Are the essence of who I am is
consciousness
when I recognize that Consciousness the
same Consciousness that in me this
Consciousness beyond the condition
itself
recognizes the Consciousness in you that
which is beyond your condition itself
and that recognition
is what Jesus called love
and therefore he said
love thy neighbor as thyself but that as
a separate statement it doesn't work but
when you put it together with Kingdom of
Heaven that then it reads
find the Kingdom of Heaven within you
the dimension of spaciousness
then you will recognize your neighbor
which is anybody that you are with
that you will recognize him or her as
yourself and this recognition that in
essence you are one that you are deeply
deeply connected that you share the one
Consciousness when you recognize them in
the other then you have suddenly an
outflow of benevolence and Good Will and
love
not the ego love but true love towards
the which in the Old Testament in the
New Testament Agape spiritual love for
another human being you can sense their
very beings
so and that's the whole secret of the of
of all spirituality it's in Jesus in the
teaching of Jesus I haven't gone through
physical death yet
as the
design master who was asked
about
life after death
said I don't know
and they said why don't you know you're
the master
and he said yeah but I'm not a dead
monster
[Music]
but I've gone very deeply to what one
could call death to identification with
form
so in a way I have gone into that Realm
from where I can say and know that
ultimately what we see as death
is the dissolution of form that the
Eternal in US
which I know that firsthand cannot be
touched by that so
what exactly happens
I would say depends on
whatever state of consciousness
you were in that was be a predominant
State of Consciousness in this lifetime
if in this lifetime
you were continuously identified with
form
your body
or the psychological form of me
that means Consciousness this expression
of consciousness
was still in a somewhat dreamlike state
which is identification with form
and
you can easily extrapolate from that if
the tendency of Consciousness to
identify with form was still there which
in other ways The Awakening had not
happened
this tendency will continue there will
be further identification with form and
the process will continue as the
Consciousness that is not yet fully
awake
will continue to identify with form
again
and then gradually come to a place where
Awakening happens or if
there has already been a
disidentification from form in this
lifetime
then you can extrapolate from there that
the compulsive urge to identify with
form and to seek another
form or another cycle of form
identification
this compulsion to seek further
experiences through through identifying
with form
then would either be much weaker
or be completely absent
in which case the Consciousness that you
are
is no longer bound
to
to this realm and will not seek to
re-experience the realm of form
but in either case
you really
I know I can tell you that all is well
does not really matter whether
this person
now needs further
experiences of identification in which
case this will happen
or whether he is already
free of this urge in which case
he will move on and
live in a realm that we can't even
conceive of
from where we are here I get a sense
deep within in the forms of what that is
but we don't need to talk about it here
all we know is
nothing
this is the beginning of the Course in
Miracles
which is the entire Course in Miracles
summarized in two lines
nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal exists
herein lies the peace of God
that which is real in him is beyond form
anybody can know that when you see a
dead body you realize that this is no
longer whom you knew this is not the
this is not the being that you knew this
is only a shell
so nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal ultimately exists
this is why
sages from all Traditions speak of this
realm of form is ultimately illusory It
ultimately it depends what level you
look at
the important thing is
all is well beyond the appearance on the
level of form which is the only level
where death exists it is a transition
from from one form
into another form or from one form into
formlessness
that is what death is no more than that
nothing real dies nothing real dies
which is to say ultimately
there is no such thing as death there
only seems to be it's a transmutation of
form either form dissolves or seek some
other form some other identification
with form Jesus often talks about
the kingdom of heaven interesting
expression and there there's a line
which I opened the Bible the other day
and I saw the line said Jesus went from
Village to Village and from town to town
and said
repent for the Kingdom of Heaven is at
hand
and the whole thing is already contained
there repent means it's Miss it's a
mistranslation repentance the original
Greek is metanoia
which means a turnaround a shift a
complete shift
so the repentance what do people think
of it as apologize or something like
that yes beat yourself up I'm such a
miserable sinner that's not that's a
missing it's a misinter interpretation
of repentance started when it was
translated into Latin into latiness
penitentia which was already wrong and
now we have metanoia as repentance no a
complete reverse a complete turnaround
in other words a shift in Consciousness
repent now what does he mean by the
Kingdom of Heaven no Christians
traditionally believed it's something
that's going to come
that she believe they completely
overlooked when they asked Jesus when
when does the Kingdom of Heaven Come he
said
the Kingdom of Heaven does not come with
observation in another translation it
says the Kingdom of Heaven does not come
with signs to be perceived you cannot
say it's over here or it's over there
for the Kingdom of Heaven is within you
now what is that thing that's within you
but you can never say it's there or it's
there
I I re-translate Kingdom of Heaven into
modern terminology
for Kingdom I would substitute dimension
and Heaven what is heaven when you look
up into heaven you see the vast Sky the
spaciousness of the sky
he used that analogy to point us an
inner reality he is used because
language usually refers to external
things that you can see and touch
so the closest that Jesus could find in
the external world to point to Something
in the inner realm was to look at the
vast spaciousness of the sky which in
itself has no particular form but is
amazing and he said the kingdom of
heaven then is heaven my translation is
spaciousness
inner spaciousness which is the
uncluttered Mind Consciousness without
conceptual without thought it's inner
alert Stillness
the dimension of spaciousness find the
dimension of that's the primordial
teaching in Jesus finds that within
yourself find the Kingdom of Heaven find
the dimension of inner spaciousness
where you're able to be alert and still
completely conscious but not thinking
and that's the essence of Jesus teaching
I have the main focus of your attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attention so that's it
from the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task then it has achieved its purpose
and that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there
that's a normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
rather be there
as shown in famous
stickers on bumper stickers on cars
which say something like I'd rather be
fishing
laughs
when I visited ramdas the spiritual
teacher who is now passed away he lived
on Maui
on his car I saw a bumper sticker which
said
I'd rather be here now our purpose here
beyond the personal purposes that we
have everybody has their personal
purpose the work you do or whatever it
is
there's a deeper purpose that the
personal purpose must be aligned with
and that deeper purpose is to live from
that deeper place
uh the way I interpret you know in the
English language doesn't have a word
that describes both men and women it's
the German language has Mensch which is
also used in Yiddish to the genre has
meant means both man or woman for a long
time I regretted that the English
language doesn't have a word for human
you have to say human being but now I'm
happy that I have to say human being
because that describes exactly the two
Dimensions the human is the conditioned
self it's a personality your historical
person which comes from the past based
on past who you are as a person that
includes your physical body and your
psychological self I call that sometimes
your form identity there's a physical
form and there's a psychological form of
you that's the human
and then there's a being the being is
the Deeper Self that is consciousness
unconditioned and no human life is
fulfilled unless the human has at least
some access
to this Dimension within them that
really is the ultimate purpose to at
least
maybe not complete access but at least
you have glimpses of that which
transcends the self to have glimpses of
self-transcendence in your life if you
you no matter how successful you are in
this world
if you have never had even a glimpse of
self-transcendence then your life is
pretty purposeless and it is very
unlikely that you will be a happy human
being
is is the ultimate Paradox with all of
this that it's almost impossible to hold
on to so even someone that has spent
their life uh trying to attain that
State uh that you can't a you can't you
to function it as a human maybe not as a
human being but just as a human uh it
would be almost impossible to constantly
be in that state in a world that doesn't
exist in that state yes not constantly
but it is possible to uh to to to not
just have that when you are perhaps
let's say engaged in spiritual practice
or you're meditating or when you're out
in nature and some happy moments out in
nature it it is our task to as much as
possible
incorporate that deeper level of
Consciousness into our daily life even
if we don't succeed all the time and
that's fine that's part of the practice
so one could say then our purpose in our
daily life beyond the personal purpose
which is also important because we need
to honor
who we are as a person to and we need to
honor our identity as a person because
no doubtedly that exists and whatever it
is that makes up your identity whether
it's mostly personal kind whether you
identify with a concern a collective
around you it could be your religion it
could whatever it might be
or the culture that you grow up in that
has its place that there's nothing wrong
with it but if that is all you know
about yourself that's very limiting so
you honor it but there's more to you
than that
and that's why the ancient Greeks said
starting from Pythagoras
500 BC
know thyself the most perhaps the most
important dictum in ancient Greek
philosophy which was carved carved on
the
walls of the Temple of Apollo at Delphi
know thyself very deep saying know who
you are in your essence
so because you have the form identity
which is a personality the fall and you
hasn't have as I call it an Essence
identity and so to know yourself at this
Essence is it called in in Indian some
in some Indian Indian spiritual
philosophy is called self-realization I
am is the word
all you can say
is I am
but you don't need you don't add
anything not this or that
I am
in the Old Testament
God is asked who are you
then that's perhaps the most profound
sentence in the Old Testament is I am
that I am
where God defines him her itself as the
I am as the essence identity of all
forms
and also another beautiful
sentence in the Old Testament as you
know the Old Testament is a mixed the
notice the Bible is a mixed bag of
fantastic things and other things
the
but I like to look for the jewels that
are there
another beautiful statement that points
to all this is
be still and know that I am God
be still and know that I am God now
these words
are all synonymous
be refers to being
still is the State of Consciousness
without thought Stillness
being and Stillness is the same thing
and no
there is a deep knowing in that in fact
it's that is because that is the source
of all
intelligence there's a deep knowing
but from the point of view of the
conceptual mind
it looks like
unknowing it looks like ignorance
because it's not knowing through
Concepts anymore it's there's a deeper
knowing and this is where what we call
wisdom arises which is very different
from intelligence the IQ kind of
intelligence
the wisdom that the world needs not more
please know
but wisdom
that yes
be still and know that I am
it is the I am of the the I am of being
God
okay here we come to a difficult word
but they're all synonymous
what is God then
I rarely talk about God because you
can't really it's so Transcendent that
whatever you say would be very limited
as you know human language and human
thought is relatively limited how can I
make statements about the ultimate
Transcendent reality
just by producing a few weird sounds
with my vocal chords
Plus
air pressure through my tongue and lips
all the vowels a i a e i o u e uh
this is what language is
okay now tell me the ultimate secrets of
God in the Transcendent universe
foreign
just produce a few sounds and that
explains no however I'll carry on
talking
[Music]
all we can do is give a an analogy or
like a poetic image of what God might be
and how God relates
to who you are
and that image is
I that I prefer
is the image of in of our you know we
can only use images from our sense
perceived universe
if the Sun is a life-giving thing in our
universe the sun gives of itself
ceaselessly for millions and millions of
years one could almost say
eternally it's not Eternal but as far as
we are concerned it's Eternal without
the sun there would be no life no
physical life here so the sun gives off
itself it emanates continuously uh the
very heat in your body ultimately comes
from the Sun so the sun if you use the
Sun as an analogy for for the the
transcendent
during the Transcendent God
has no location in space or time God is
neither there or if we have to say
anything we could say God is right here
because it's Transcendent to this
dimension
so if we use this as an analogy the the
Transcendent emanates into this
Dimension something that creates
form that creates life and what It
ultimately this thing that it emanates
is consciousness at first very little at
first Consciousness appears as as it
were frozen as minerals and stones and
then Consciousness becomes as if it were
liquid if we use energy of water then it
becomes vegetative life then again
Consciousness gradually evolves so one
Consciousness more of it comes in then
you get animal life it's like and then
you get human life it becomes ethereal
it's a human mind
emanating from the source of all life
that is transcendent of which you cannot
say anything
into this world as the sun emanates
light
the god emanates Consciousness and this
brings about this universe and in this
universe it's a process it grows
in the transcendent
we don't know anything about that so
not the important thing is
the ray of sunlight that you come that
hits your hand you feel the warmth on
your hands
that Ray it's not the sun you couldn't
say I have the sun on my hand I mean if
you got close to the Sun you would
immediately disappear but this Ray of
sunlight is still connected to the sun
in some way it is still part of the sun
we can't even say where the sun exactly
ends it doesn't really end anywhere it
doesn't have a clearly defined surface
it extends outward
so it emanates continuously
so what the what the source of all life
emanates is consciousness
and you can sense that
in yourself
when you can sense
yourself as Consciousness the presence
then you are then you realize this the
Ripple on the surface of the ocean
has realized
that it is not only a ripple I'm mixing
analogies now
it's not only a ripple more
fundamentally the Ripple is the ocean
and suddenly the Ripple is no longer no
longer fearful
because it can sense its deep
connectedness
to that which is vast and
all-encompassing
and so the ripples only
lives in a different way because it
realizes
its own Timeless essence
or the Sun the ray of sunlight could do
the same it could suddenly become aware
that it is still connected and part of
the sun it can and you can sense in
yourself
the undoubted fact that you are
conscious
but not only that
we're creating a duality here that
doesn't exist when we say that you are
conscious
the essence of who you are is
consciousness so you are Consciousness I
often say say yes to the present moment
or I say
make the present moment your friend not
your enemy
so it's a to say yes to the present
moment is a powerful teaching but it can
be misunderstood and has been
misunderstood sometimes and it needs to
be explained what that actually means it
means
oh by the way
um
there's a funny movie made a few some
years ago with Jim Carrey it's called
the Yes Man
and this is a person in the movie a
character the character he plays
he works at a bank I think to in the
mortgage department and he's very he's
very bitter and he likes to say no to
people who apply for mortgages every no
you can't have any Lovesick and it's
very negative about everything now his
life is
the uneventful boring everything is
negative then he goes to a new age a
friend invites him to a strange New Age
event with a new age teacher and the
teacher says you have to say yes
to everything say yes to everything and
he kind of
becomes convinced well I might as well
try that I've got nothing to lose
and from then on whatever people ask him
every mortgage he approves and whatever
people ask him can you lend me money
sure yes can you do this yes yes yes yes
and then his life becomes very
interesting but also very chaotic he
gets into most chaotic situations and he
kind of all gets out of hand and
I
and in the end he kind of seems to
realize that this wasn't quite working
it's that that was that is not the true
meaning
so to say yes to the present moment does
not mean that you accept everything that
people ask of you
in some cases you have to use the now
the no
but in the
um non but not
in an angry way that denies the present
moment I call that
a high quality no
so it's let's say
um in the August can you look after my
children or let's begin because I need
your yourself so good with certain the
seal flatter you you feel obliged you're
such a wonderful person I say I love you
can you do it again please and at some
point safety I'm sorry I can't do it
anymore
um but without
any negativity a simple statement it is
not a reactive statement you don't make
her into a bad person I know she you
want to take advantage of me I'm not
doing it anymore that is a low quality
now
even if perhaps you she did try to
perhaps she was trying to take advantage
of you but that is not that maybe then a
dysfunction in her egoic self many
humans do that the world is full of
people who perhaps are trying to take
advantage of you that's what the egos do
and so it's not who she truly is but you
speak to you do not speak to the ego in
her you simply say
I love your children they're just
wonderful and I enjoyed my time but I
can't do it anymore I'm sorry about that
high quality no no no I can't do that a
person says can you lend me another
thousand dollars
um and you do well I've already lent you
2 000 three months ago and last year I
lent you five thousand I haven't got
anything back yet
and then it's I'm sorry I have to say no
but you don't say
did you adjust you're just trying to
accuse me
and I'm not going to do that anymore I'm
not going to be used anymore by you this
is it that's it I know more that that's
another kind of no but it's a low
quality no
and the high quality knows no I'm sorry
that's it I can't do that anymore
it implies there is a presence behind
what you say it's not reactive
and with the same the person who asked
you to write something you say I've seen
the background I'm not in agreement with
that therefore I'm sorry I need to say
no to this I can't do this thank you
high quality knobs it's beautiful and it
works quite often you may have to use
that make sure that it's not reactive
and then becomes low quality when I
meditate
dream fear often arises in my mind I
feel like I would be destroyed or
completely disappeared so I stopped
meditation because of the fear I'm so
afraid to keep going on although I
intuitively know that bearing the fear
would get me closer to Enlightenment how
can I conquer this fear
this is yes of course the fear of the
person the personalized sense of self or
the ego
which can feel
threatened
by the arising awareness and once you
know that
you can still meditate and allow the
fear to be there it's only when you try
to run away from the fear that really it
becomes a great obstacle
but if you can be with the fear allow
the fear to be there as on a pure energy
level Feel the fear
then
you will find it begins to dissolve
so rather than not wanting to feel it
allow yourself to feel it
then this is the beginning of change
if you always run away from it
then
it'll linger there's no change
there's a book called think feel the
fear and do it anyway or something like
that but that is a quite good advice
although I mean not applied necessarily
to everything
I'm going to jump off now
but to allow yourself to feel whatever
feeling comes is part of the present the
what the is-ness of the present moment
so if the fear Rises but then you also
realize what is is the fear created by a
thought you will know that or is the
fear arising just by itself in a
particular situation when you become
still
do you have a fear of Silence do you
feel uncomfortable when you go into a
room and there's there's no noise in it
some people do feel some people are
uncomfortable in nature
it's not noisy enough
so see it may be that the fear arises
when you when you become still you
meditate then it's not necessarily
associated with the thought
but with that arising of awareness and
instead of British stopping your
meditation
just what happens if I just carry on and
make the fear into a meditation meditate
on the fear so in when if you do
meditate
nothing really can disturb you with the
good meditator
incorporates whatever arises in the
present moment into the meditation
including the most irritating noise that
suddenly starts up outside
and the mind says I can't meditate now
I need Stillness and then you realize no
perhaps this is part of the meditation
and how does it become part of the
meditation
by allowing the isness of this moment
which is that by just letting go of
resistance allow whatever it is to be
and if it comes from within
fear anxiety you allow that to be but
you have to be careful that it doesn't
become a thought
because the moment you are drawn back
into thinking that's the end of your
meditation
you can allow a thought to be there but
to order to allow a soul to be there
that that
implies that there is some awareness
there behind the thoughts or you are
still there
if so to be able it's a wonderful thing
do you allow the thought to be that's
very different from being drawn into the
thought and following it where it wants
to take you of course that's the end of
your meditation or your mindfulness or
whatever you want to call it I don't use
mindfulness as you know because
it's not about a full mind
that's why I avoid the word mindfulness
but mindfulness is a lovely thing it's
really its presence
so you can follow a sword it takes it
grabs you it grabs all your attention
and pulls you along that's one way
or you can realize there's authorizing
about
what my ex-spouse did five years ago to
me
while I'm meditating
and you can allow the thoughts to arise
instantly be aware and if you do that
instead of being pulled into it then you
will find that it quickly it arises and
it subsides so then it becomes very much
like you know the sky
in this one let's say you have a blue
sky and clouds occasionally come so the
clouds are the thoughts that arise in
the mind
the blue skies the vastness of that
space is your awareness
so clouds are not a problem if
within the larger context of the aware
presence
they come and go and they might be
thoughts that say ridiculous things
there might be a thought about
I'd like to eat a
apple pie now I really need to eat apple
pie the Minecraft is the most absurd
things to interrupt your meditation
can you imagine an apple pie you're
eating
and then you know there's the thought of
apple pie you allow that to be you don't
get drawn into the apple pie sauce or
even suddenly you have to get up and run
to the fridge to see if there's an apple
pie is still in there
the thought arises you are the sky
that's the awareness
and the thought is what comes into the
awareness now if more and more thoughts
come
or if you follow one of the cloud
thoughts that drift into the space of
awareness one of the cloud thoughts and
you suddenly go it it it grabs hold of
you and you follow it and the cloud gets
bigger
then it attracts other clouds that
correspond to it they suddenly come from
out of nowhere
and then you are in a big cloud you're
still sitting there trying to meditate
but you're really in a big cloud of
thought
and before you know it
the entire sky is
cloudy all totally overcast
now of course there's still some light
shining through the clouds but you'd no
longer know where that comes from
there's some light of of course
Consciousness sword cannot exist without
Consciousness thought is a manifestation
of consciousness
but so there's the Consciousness that is
behind the thoughts but you don't no
longer know that Consciousness directly
only through the filter of thoughts in
the same way that you don't know the
sunlight anymore except to the filter of
the clouds I'm surprised there's nothing
on Google about Eckhart and free will
but maybe maybe I haven't said anything
about it
uh
so here we go
as you know it's an it's an eternal
ancient philosophical question and
there's never been a definitive answer
but that everybody would agree with in
that sense
so is there Australian you mentioned
everybody's doing their best because
every nobody can act beyond their level
of Consciousness etc for example okay
let's start from on one level
uh
and then we go on to the next level
on on the level of egoic
unconsciousness where you are a
conditioned entity your your mental
emotional makeup
extra totally conditioned by the past
and you are completely identified with
the conditioning of your of your mind
and in that state that spiritually
speaking is the unconscious state it is
obvious that in that state there is no
Freedom at all because you are forced to
act out the unconscious conditioning of
your mind with which you are completely
identified
so I think most people would probably
agree if you understand
that that on that level
there is no possibility of Freedom their
actions are determined by the
unconditioned mind you are forced to act
as you do because there's no choice
because choice would imply some
awareness
so on that level there's certainly no
freedom
then
awareness comes in the human being
begins to awaken then it appears I'm not
saying it is the case
it appears that then the human the free
Freedom
begins to be a possibility because
you can
choose
to step out of the conditioning of your
mind you can recognize a conditioned
thought
and do you are no longer compelled to
act it out because there is an awareness
there you can choose a certain cause of
action not not from the conditioning of
your mind but from the the presence so
you can you can you can act and you have
much more freedom that before you could
not have freedom comes with
awareness
so it's then relative to the unconscious
day there is now freedom to act
but
if you look more deeply even there
even there on that level you are
connected with the totality of
Consciousness you're only an expression
of the totality of Consciousness you are
not really a separate entity you are a
like a who said it you are was it Alan
Watts who said you are you in the same
way that the the wave is something that
the ocean is doing
you are something that the whole
universe is doing in the same same way
so the wave is something the ocean is
doing you are something that the
universe is doing
so although it appears from a certain
relative to the previous state of
unconsciousness there is freedom and
relative to that there is freedom but
then if you look more deeply into that
you realize that even there one cannot
say that you are choosing this speak you
are an expression of Consciousness and
Consciousness one could say is choosing
and you think you're doing it sometimes
people ask me can you choose to be
present uh and you know from one
perspective you can choose to be present
from another perspective
one could say that the presence chooses
you it chooses to become present through
you depends how you look at it
so in Ultimate terms of the in relative
terms
there is freedom relative to the
unconscious State when you become more
conscious but even there it's only
relative to the unconscious State even
there there is no not absolute freedom
because you do not exist as an
independent entity you are a part of the
web of interconnectedness that is the
whole universe so in that sense there is
no freedom of choice of the individual
because ultimately there is no
individual I have the main focus of your
attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attentions of that say
the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task then it has achieved its purpose
and that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there
that's a normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
to rather be there
at as shown in the famous
stickers on bumper stickers on cars
which say something like I'd rather be
fishing the sense of being an outsider
is also something that
I have had
throughout my life
and
the sense of
not belonging here
watching my parents
being engaged
in continuous
conflict
not because they were bad people they
were they did what they did and they
loved me as best they could
and they did what they did
as a reflection of their state of
consciousness at that time which was a
normal State of Consciousness egoic
state of consciousness
but I sometimes felt how did I get here
yeah
somehow didn't there must have been a
mistake
um
it's often
Outsiders
on as being feeling an outsider on the
one hand is
seems a terrible limitation that you
can't participate
as much on the other hand it's a great
opportunity because
some of the most creative people
in the world have where have been
Outsiders they did not fit in
Misfits it's the English word Misfits
um
another the friendships I had
when I was a child
and that's another interesting thing I
had to
friend one of my friends was it was
severely
physically
disabled
and nobody else wanted to
be friends with him because of that and
he was probably my closest friend
and the other one was so weird that
nobody wanted to talk to him
but he became my friend so they were
Outsiders too
and
dot but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me
that there are people here from 70
countries it seems almost unbelievable
but it's true I saw the list
70 countries and you may find I'm sure
you will find
quite often
you you you can feel a bond or yeah you
have more in common
with many of the people who are here
then you have with your own people in
your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual Awakening
who are still totally conditioned 100
conditioned by their culture so you feel
a connectedness here with other humans
that transcends culture and conditioning
and all this silly political stuff it
transcends that and this is a wonderful
thing
so to some extent you can now connect
with people even if you don't always see
them physically you might live I don't
know whether you live in a big city or a
small village
City small City yeah yeah world city in
spoke in Austria oh yes yeah nice very
nice
I don't know how many people in
Innsbruck are 120
000 and how many of those are
Awakening we don't know
we don't know of course but this helps I
believe being here and feeling you are
not alone
you are connected
so this would be a help for the rest you
just have to accept that this is how it
is
no matter how hard you try to fit in
on the normal level you probably won't
nor do you have to so I know this there
are many people here who feel that and
be happy with it but don't make it into
some kind of superiority because the ego
can always creep in
before you know it there's always a back
door and then the ego is back in so you
can you could go from feeling bad about
being an outsider to suddenly feeling
okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior and then so to have to be
careful and don't go there so um
that's just how it is if you you
probably would not be here if you had
not been an outfelt like an outsider for
many years so it worked you won't really
enjoy the fruit of your labors
if habitually you cannot be present in
the moment
no matter what you achieve the enjoyment
will be short-lived because of the
habitual pattern
of dissatisfaction in the background
it's always there some obscure sense of
lack and often it comes into the
foreground as real unhappiness
frustration
and then if you realize that there's
always this waiting for the next thing
which is a thought when you're waiting
for the next thing you're trapped in
thought because that's what future
happens
now
the realization that this is happening
to you is very important the first step
is the beginning of something else
arising
and in all of you that has already
Arisen or that occasionally it still
gets obscured perhaps probably I assume
something else hasn't risen that's not
thought that is beyond thought the
ability to recognize thought
the ability to recognize certain
patterns that habitually arise in your
mind your mental emotional field
the ability to witness that which arises
in your mental emotional field
that's an enormous
believing consciousness
another dimension one could say has a
risen
we could call it presence we could call
it awareness
it's not thought
but it's intelligence
so intelligence is not confined to
thought
there is a dimension in you
that is far
greater far more intelligence than any
intelligent thought
it's the place from where all
intelligence arises a place of where all
creativity arises
[Music]
foreign
so there's the ability to suddenly be
aware of your inner states to be aware
of what's what your mind is saying the
The Narrative the habitual narrative
that you're telling yourself you're
having a monologue or many people have a
dialogue with themselves where they
split themselves in two and then this
one argues with the other why aren't you
good enough why did you do this why do
you never get anything right you
shouldn't have he shouldn't have said
that yes but on the other so you can
have a dialogue in your narrative or you
can have a monologue it says I am such a
miserable creature because a lot of the
time the narratives the unconscious
thought processes tend to be more
negative than positive for many many
people
so to be aware that this is happening
that's an enormous gain in continence
it's the beginning of Awakening oh
spiritually speaking
something arises that is not part of the
conditioned mind patterns
so there's the ability to observe your
inner states and that's a wonderful
little pointer to ask yourself
[Music]
frequently
wants my inner State at this moment
and then look at it direct your
attention to it the narratives what have
I been telling myself
and the emotion that accompanies The
Narrative
what am I feeling what's the emotion
so in addition to it being a story in
your head and an emotion
there's a knowing behind it
there's a space behind it
sometimes I call it Inner Space there's
an inner space
from where you can be aware of what's
Happening
on the level of the person the
personality
because that Inner Space the awareness
is not part of the personality it's but
it's the being
the knowing that it's inherent in the
being you can look at the world wars you
can look at all the the terrorism and
all the other mad Wars that are being
fought
as just
it's just a question of degrees of
unconsciousness not different
so when you go into that state of
unconsciousness you it takes you over
you lose it
basically then that is the same energy
field
that has created
what we see as the Mad Madness of human
history
and what we see of The Madness of the
so-called world news
the same energy so don't complain about
all these violent people who are doing
all these Dreadful things all that it is
is human or unconsciousness in a more
pronounced form than yours
or your partners
and
so
that helps a little bit to find perhaps
almost some compassion
towards
all these crazy people
that are doing such crazy things and
creating such terrible suffering now if
you become compassionate towards them
don't worry
it doesn't mean that they will not
experience
the consequences of their
unconsciousness that still happens you
just by being compassionate to another
human being you don't necessarily remove
the karmic consequences of their action
but
you yourself
become free from the
from being drawn into the karmic cycle
so the
the act of forgiveness
does not mean
that this person is not going to suffer
the consequences because life makes sure
in whatever form that they do suffer the
consequences of the suffering that they
inflict on other human beings it's a
karmic law
but if you don't want to be part of that
anymore if you want to step out of the
karmic law the the first step out of the
and the most important step out of the
karmic law is forgiveness
then you do not feed it you don't become
part of it that's why traditionally in
spiritual teachings of various
traditions
forgiveness is always emphasized it must
be real though it's there are many forms
of superficial forgiveness when Justin
minus okay I forgive you it's not deep
it's not real yet
the mind is trying to forgive but you
you can only forgive
if you realize that whatever actions
have been perpetrated are the effects of
human unconsciousness
in other words what Jesus said on the
cross or is reported to have said
forgive them for they know not what they
do
very profound statement it is a profound
statement that can be applied to any Act
of
violence perpetrated against other
humans or life forms forgive them for
they know not what they do
not knowing what they do of course means
they are unconscious
the word unconscious probably in that
sense wasn't used at the time
so he said they don't know what they do
karmic law still operates
but without you
and you can notice karmic law
[Music]
when when you see a movie some movies
like to manipulate your emotions
and so there are particular types of
movies where they first they build up
the tension by showing you some very
evil persons
and this evil person is killing all
these people or hurting all these people
and then you're being manipulated
to feel that incredible pull that this
person should suffer for what he or she
has done that's the manipulation the
audience loves it they love watching
things like that
so then the emotion builds up and
finally there even some movies like The
the movies that uh about um
Vigilantes who take justice in their own
hands because the justice system doesn't
deal with the criminals anymore so
finally you have this guy who goes out
and kills all the bad guys and the your
emotions have been manipulated so much
that the audience that yes yes he must
die not realize no what you what you are
free what what you are feeling this
incredible it might also happen if you
read about some Dreadful crime that
somebody has committed and then if you
read it on the internet the you can read
in some on some news websites you can
read the comment section
and in the comment section on every
other comment says we should have the
death penalty who needs to say electric
chair he needs to be
done to what he did did he they should
do to him and all these and this is an
enormous pressure that people feel
inside and this is connected to karmic
law because there's a competence
compensatory factor in karmic law and
you can feel that as the pressure inside
you but it keeps you trapped in karma
huh so in that sense watching these
movies is not helpful
because it keeps you trapped in that
that wheel of the of karma
so they don't teach forgiveness there so
this is we are talking it's about
something very important and that is
dealing with human unconsciousness and
what looks like evil
they saw there are many things that uh
quite Dreadful so how do we how does
that affect our state of consciousness
and what role does our state of
consciousness play in this whole
scenario it does have a role to play
so it's
for us
important
that we are no longer part of
action and reaction because the
definition of karma is action comma
means action and reaction and it goes on
and on and as you can see in certain
societies and so on the karmic thing
goes on what goes back centuries and
centuries the same grievance
transmitted from one generation to the
next and the next and the next and they
are all asleep
this is why spiritual teaching say that
you are asleep they are all so
unconscious they get taken over by the
collective mental emotional pattern and
the mental story they just inherited
from their parents and then they pass it
on to their children and then they and
each generation suffers they suffer they
coma suffering think right for each each
other
and at some point
the suffering becomes almost unbearable
for certain people within that society
and that's the beginning of
a shift when it gets too much so
suffering drives humans
to appoint
of Awakening it's a strange Paradox here
is
the suffering is created by the
unconsciousness in humans
but in some strange way
eventually it wakes you up it awakens
you
that's the redeeming feature behind the
suffering that humans create for each
other
eventually it leads to a spiritual
awakening
so
it always a good thing to realize it all
comes down to your state of
consciousness
and how you relate to the people around
you and that spreads that is what
creates the world
and even how you react to when you
listen to the world news
that has a certain influence because all
[Music]
all human minds are connected at a
deeper level
so the way in which you react to what
you hear on the world news contributes
either to the unconsciousness if you get
on the on your computer or the iPad and
you type in this guy does not deserve to
live
[Music]
he should be
die slowly
then you become part of the same Karma
if you've ever done that please forgive
yourself
and if you enjoy reading those comments
also forgive yourself certain actions
take place you do things you know
they are not
the optimal things to do but you can't
help it it's something
acts through you
um there seems to be some power there
that makes you do things
that you know no are not right or not
good for you and yet you can't stop it
that seems to be the case
um
and that of course
is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but
um
this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to
a certain substance or who are addicted
to eating too much or drinking
there's something that overpowers them
in you that seems to obscure
the awareness
or the awareness is pushed to to recite
and this thing this this powerful thing
does it anyway
and again my answer is a little bit
similar to
um
what I say to the first question tonight
the
the power of presence
needs to grow in you so that
it is strong enough not to it's not
willpower because willpower is not
the best way of dealing with these
things but
it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the application of a
force to hold something down let's say
um
if you're addiction is to
have a to indulge in
intoxicating beverages in other words
booze is the British word then
and you can feel it it comes on there it
comes you know the bottles are there
there they are and you feel you have to
go then you have to reach out and you
have to pour yourself a drink now
when you're not aware at all you don't
even know what you're doing you're so
unconscious that you you're already
holding the drink and you're drinking
then you at that point you you even know
that you're drinking
the same with food I've spoken to people
who've had addictions to food they often
say they wake up when they're ready
they've already eaten in the middle of
the night they've already unconsciously
gone to the fridge taking out the
chocolate cake and then they're already
halfway through the chocolate cake when
somebody's like what am I doing
but so awareness comes in at a very late
point
willpower would be to hold an urge down
that say oh God they have to pull or
even what the example you gave you want
to turn on the TV and you know it's not
right because I I'm not here for that
and he actually told us not to do it
help it I have to go I can't I can't no
willpower you would you would say I'm
going to hold this I'm not going to do
it
I can confirm the odds but you're
holding it down
[Laughter]
when you hold things down
often after a while
an explosion happens it's like a boiling
kettle
can't hold it for that long and then you
have some kind of rationalization in
your mind but it's you'll do it anyway
the mind will give you a reason first
you see the need to be a victim identity
also unfortunately is a form of ego
because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be employees justified in having a
victim identity because of the things
that other humans did to you you
yourself are finding you are finding
yourself in a kind of prison
that created by your mind
so there's no denial of that bad things
happen to you yes
now question is
how do you exit
this mental present
the first step is perhaps to see
[Music]
um
that
unconscious human beings
unconscious human beings in the grip of
their own conditioning their own ego
they have virtually no free will
when you are unconscious you are
controlled by
the the Mind patterns that are lodged in
your psyche
you have you cannot really speak of Free
Will by somebody who has zero awareness
and the entire makeup is uh conditioning
from the past
so the famous sentence phrase used by
Jesus
in connection with forgiveness on the
cross he said forgive them for they know
not what they do
now these these two interesting these
points put together
forgive them why forgive them
they know not what they do in other
words if he had spoken these days using
our terminology
he probably would have said they are
completely unconscious
because that's what it means they know
not what they do they are completely
unconscious
so when you see nobody can act beyond
their level of consciousness
then you see that it's almost like it
becomes almost like the evil that was
perpetrated it becomes almost like a
natural phenomenon
that is like you've been hit by
lightning or something or
lived in very unpleasant
climatic conditions that that injured
you
near volcano
and my dad what had problems with anger
huge outbursts of anger quite frequently
it was living like living the Lake
Street volcano they could erupt at any
moment
um
and he could not help it it was it was
impossible there was no possibility of
being different
and so these humans are run by
unconscious conditioning it usually goes
back to their childhood and what
happened there
I know why my father was angry I I
needed I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the the
reasons why he was so angry and also
for a while also I felt a resentment
towards that and only when I was able to
awaken out of egoic consciousness
I saw that there's nothing that he could
have done differently because there
wasn't enough awareness
now
when you see that then you don't
personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that their first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their conditioning
in the absence of awareness
if there's awareness they can transcend
their conditioning and then they begin
to become conscious of their own
conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes
so they couldn't
they can't help it so that's that's
already a useful step in forgiveness but
you may not yet be able to arrive at at
full forgiveness because of that another
before I continue with that
does that mean then a question may arise
in your mind
doesn't mean then humans are not really
responsible for what they do
if they are unconscious how are they
responding does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them from what they do
if they commit a crime
are they not guilty
that's an interesting question
the the unconsciousness
that operates in human even if you are
able to forgive a human when we come we
will go more fully into that in a minute
even if you're able to forgive and human
for their transgressions or whatever
they did
this does not mean and even though the
human is not responsible for their
unconsciousness and yet
it is built into the
structure of human life
they still need to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness is
religion necessary it depends who you
are on the level of the form for some
people it can be necessary or helpful
for two reasons
it can provide the more superficial
reason
it can give your life a certain amount
of structure which for some people can
be helpful
regular practice
gives you a feeling of comfort
some people have too little structure in
their lives and others have too much
already
if you have too little structure in your
life then religion can provide
that
more importantly on another level
religion can either obscure
the
spiritual Dimension within yourself and
often it does
or
if used rightly if approached rightly if
understood
on a deeper level
it can
help you
access and stay in connectedness
with that deeper level of yourself or
the Transcendent dimension of
consciousness
whether or not you need it only you can
know whether you find it either helpful
or a hindrance
we can be either depend depends on
you as a person your past what function
it had in your past
and so on
it is a hindrance
if religion becomes an ideology
then it operates only on the level of
the Mind
and it's very similar to any other kind
of ideology that you may believe in
whether it's
don't know
communism as a as an ideology or any
political Theory or anything that
explains the universe it could be a
metaphysical system that you completely
believe in
philosophical system and so on
so an ideology is something that takes
possession of your mind
and exerts
a controlling function
[Music]
and it can influence
almost the entire mental functioning if
it becomes something of a
overwhelming power in your mind it's a
it's a little thought that grows into a
huge thing in your mind and the
tentacles breeds into every aspect of
your mind and there are religious people
like that
uh
usually you can recognize that it is an
ideology
by the fact that they are not peaceful
human beings
and by the fact that
they have
enemies
either even within their own religion
or another religion anybody who does not
agree with their ideology
becomes an enemy in the same way the
people who were not nowadays that many
were deeply believing in communism which
was a wonderful idea to start with of
course
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions it was a beautiful idea of
equality
everybody the same and that is wonderful
no personal possessions so it's
wonderful too
and the only mistake was
it was imposed from outside by people
who themselves has not gone beyond the
egoic State of Consciousness they just
played it in their mind isn't that's a
good idea
and then it was imposed on on other
people who also were not in that state
of consciousness but most importantly
those who impose the idea on others
forced them to live it out
the ideal became contaminated with ego
so when these people came to power
the egos
became inflated to an enormous degree
absurdity and without realizing it
they
re-enacted
the same
evils in some cases worse than those
that they were fighting against
I don't remember who said it but then
Master said it
don't seek
for the trolls
just
cease or stop
cherishing opinions
hmm
that is as I believe points to the same
in a state of
disidentification from
thinking
she doesn't cling to ideas
cling to it doesn't mean she doesn't
have ideas the master
but the master does not cling to ideas
and the Zen master when he said
don't look for the truth
just stop cherishing opinions
he didn't say
stop having opinions just as loud say
does not say
don't have ideas
says don't cling to ideas and the other
Master says
stop cherishing opinions
so this clinging
which is the same as cherishing is
self-identification with
thoughts that arise
in other words
you then believe
completely
in every thought that comes into your
head amazing
you believe in it that means
you are it
you
that is self
identification with thinking
so
how then to be at one always add one
with the dowel so simple
on the one hand you could call it stop
cherishing opinions now any thought that
arises ultimately is an opinion you
could say stop cherishing stop your
self-identification with that
or don't cling to ideas in the words of
loud say or the this present translation
here
so that there's always a space between
you and your thoughts that you and or
rather
you are not the thought you are the
space for the thought that is how I put
it sometimes you're familiar with that
and perhaps you in yourself you know it
you don't have to be
in your thoughts but you can be the
space for your thoughts
then no matter how weird your thoughts
are it doesn't matter that much you
don't say oh my God I shouldn't be
having these weird thoughts no because
that's another thought
laughs
I'm spiritually I'm supposed to be
spiritually Advanced and why am I still
having these thoughts there must be
something wrong with me
does it sound familiar
that's also thoughts that's more
thoughts that say I shouldn't be having
these thoughts there's something wrong
with me or and then you believe in those
thoughts
thoughts that judge other thoughts
that may sound familiar to some of you
and there's nothing personal in it it's
the human mind
so you don't need to
eliminate thoughts or just say I should
only have pure thoughts because
I'm a spiritual person
because
by now I should say transcended
all impure thoughts
well
then you're in a dilemma because
in this world of polarities if you only
want to have pure thoughts you're
creating the other polarity
in the Unseen and sooner or later
the other polarity
will come up from behind creep up
and this has been done sometimes by
Christians who try to practice the
teachings of Christ without entering the
State of Consciousness out of which it
comes so they try to be pure and
spiritual and good Christians
and denied
the other polarity repressed it
and then suddenly they get overpowered
by something deeply destructive and
negative so you have these occasion you
have a nice wonderful
person always talks in spirituals just
sold and spiritual and before you know
it he's screaming at his wife or even
hitting his wife
where did that come from
and he can't even admit to himself that
this is what's happening
and so if you push away certain thoughts
that you because they do not fit into
the mental image of Who You Are
as this or that then
they get it because assume a life of
Their Own
and before you know it they invade your
mind again if only in your dreams and
suddenly you have Dreadful nightmares
during a day you're such a spiritual
person and at night you suddenly have
Dreadful nightmares monsters come or you
become a monster oh my God this
shouldn't be happening
and that's because
you're pushing something away
the true spiritual does not lie in one
thought or another thought it lies in
being there as the space for your
thoughts
then it doesn't matter anymore really
any whatever thought arises is no more
than that it's a form that arises at
this moment
you don't resist it you don't need to
resist it
but you are the space right you don't
become it
somebody sent me a sticker to put on the
car I haven't put it on my car yet A
very wise stick I don't know where it
originated it says you don't need to
believe every thought you think
laughs
so this is the practice then of
being the space or the witness for your
thoughts rather than being the thought
and you can practice with your opinions
many thoughts are actual most thoughts
can all thoughts could be called
opinions but there are certain things
that are definitely clearly recognizable
as opinions when you are talking to
people every day when you're having a
discussion or talk with friends or
colleagues or Neighbors
so they will Express their opinion
whatever it may be about and you may
express your opinion
and you can then observe whether or not
there is self-identification with your
opinion and your opinion of course is a
mental position
in the position of the Mind are you
identified with a mental position if you
are then you are cherishing opinions in
the words of the Zen master or you are
clinging to ideas in the words of loud
say
and how do you know that
you know that when as you discuss things
you become
either defensive or aggressive in the
expression of your opinion
emotion flows into
and you get worked up in oh why is that
happening why are you becoming defensive
or aggressive
and of course you have to look inside
yourself to see whether this is the case
or not are you becoming defensive or
aggressive
you feel the influx of emotion
and why is this happening because
unconsciously
you feel threatened
by somebody who attracts or questions or
contradicts
your mental position why do you feel
threatened by somebody who questions
your mental position
that is a sign that you had identified
with a mental position and identified
means your sense of self was in it so
the person is not attacking your opinion
in your unconscious Viewpoint the person
you're being attacked in your your very
alive is being is under attack because
he identified this this is not true but
this is how it is perceived as if they
were attacking your very existence
because you identified with a mental
position there was a self in it
so anybody who questions it questions
your very existence it's unconscious
process
so that's an amazing thing to realize in
yourself and it's a deep seated
unconscious pattern in most human beings
and of course
as you become conscious of that you can
usually see it much more clearly in
others more easily
in your friend or whoever you're having
then in yourself
usually says oh yes that's what he
always does
of course now I understand what my
husband or my wife does I understand
completely that step one an allotment is
required to truly truly perceive things
and immediately Things become more life
and less problematic
when you're going to censorship because
the problematic Dimension is in the head
and you're going to send medicine
suddenly you have into the present
moment and in the present moment
problems
disappear isn't that strange that the
mind says well I still have them
yeah when you start thinking about them
you have them again
but when you're not thinking about them
you have no problems now some of you
will argue with that but let me explain
you have situations in your life that
can be challenging and you have to deal
with these situations
but the only place where you can deal
with the challenging situations is in
the present moment
and dealing with a challenging situation
in the present moment is not a problem
you're dealing with a challenging
situation you're facing it you're
looking at it
and that looking is important what I
call looking really is
paying putting your attention on it
which is The Power Of Consciousness and
while you're looking you're not thinking
every person who has achieved mastery
in any field knows what I mean by
looking
because there isn't that absolute
presence and then that person does what
he or she does is it flows it flows from
that presence
so you look there's no problem
promise when you dwell mentally on
something that will happen Could Happen
might happen a problem that's something
I have to face next week but not now
and you're totally absorbed in that
that's a problem
an interesting thing I may have even
written that in the path now
if you think you have problems ask
yourself
what problem do I have at this moment
but this moment really means this moment
and then you have to go hmm
well I've got um my wife my ex-wife is
suing me
I'm about to lose my home
passing close to me is ill I might lose
my job
I have to look for a new job okay what
problem do you have at this moment
[Music]
you're breathing feeling the aliveness
in the body looking around well well at
this moment I don't actually have a
problem
you have to then admit
if you really go into the present moment
the problem cannot survive in the
present moment but
it's an amazing realization doesn't mean
that you no longer deal with what you
need to deal with
you deal with it when the moment comes
more effectively when you don't waste
your life energy
in the mental realm of creating problems
that you cannot be dealt with at this
moment
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night thinking about your problems and
what you can do about them it's it's
extremely unlikely that you find any
Solution by worrying at four o'clock in
the morning about it
but if you came still at four o'clock in
the morning and wake up and go into the
inner energy field of the body rather
than thinking about your problems in
other words leave the dimension of
problems come deeply into the present
moment
then perhaps the next morning when you
wake up
oh I know what I have to do now I know
how I can deal with it now and the right
cause of action happens because you've
gone there but not through the problem
making faculty in the human mind
so again coming back to your question
when things are when you're not not
being challenged
practice it
and then when you are being challenged
by
little things that goes wrong so to
speak in daily life tends to happen you
might have noticed
things don't always go according to your
expectations sometimes you miss the bus
or something you miss the plane or
something else goes wrong
it tends to happen actually quite a lot
it seems to be part of life
that's by the way it's the reason why
people go to see movies
because the substructure of every movie
that you see we could call it
it applies to virtually every movie you
see if you can examine any movie you see
what actually happens in the movie
exactly I can describe every movie to
you in three words
something goes wrong
because there wouldn't be a movie
otherwise nothing would happen
nobody would evolve
would everything would be dead but in
your own life you complain so you go
you'd see movies to see something go
wrong but when it happens in your own
life you complain and not you personally
you've transcended it perhaps already
but so the strange thing is it's things
are not meant not to go wrong going
wrong is part of the totality of how
life experiences itself
if things didn't go wrong
there would be very uninteresting and
nobody would evolve because people only
evolve through the challenges that they
encounter and in a good movie
the protagonist or the character
changes as he or she faces the pro that
which goes wrong in the movie in a bad
movie
so to speak the character does not go
through any changes the that which goes
wrong is only solved on an external
level the in the end the bad guy is
killed and that's the end of the movie
but nothing else happens so
something going wrong is part of how
life experiences itself and again you
can then bring awareness to that
so that you don't always fall into
reactivity when something goes wrong
but you immediately align with it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible jodus spends on motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there when you begin to
create from the field instead of from
matter the only way you can do that is
you have to learn how to take all of
your attention off your body and become
a nobody take all of your attention off
all the people in your life that you
give so much of your attention